in five four
three two hd welcome
to the h3h3 it's not even h3 welcome to
the late podcast trying to make a joke
about being late
thank you for being patient to be fair
it is only bad luck
ethan thank you keemstar it's so nice
that keemstar wish me good luck every
time we
make an episode it's very sweet
thoughtful of him
uh we're only 10 minutes late so it's
not like you know could have been worse
but i do apologize i mean we've been
work we've been later
15 minutes back in the day dan we used
to hit that we still hit like 43 like
man we just do it the next day right we
just skipped the damn day
no i'm kidding we'll do it live you know
today's been
the week's been a little bit weird we um
our video that our normal podcast that
we were meant to upload yesterday
didn't get approved in time the youtube
gods did not look
favorably favorably upon us
so it is up for members and now is a
good time
to plug our membership if you become a
member and help support the show
you get episodes a day early
and that episode is up there basically
how it works is that we submit
our podcasts ahead of time for youtube
to evaluate and this is their system to
make sure
that it doesn't get like mature rated
and yellowed because
it's actually a really great program
that youtube made for you know people
like us who actually have businesses and
employees and we depend
on these episodes making money
so they devised a pretty ingenious and
amazing program where you submit
a video and they give you feedback
and then or or they approve it but if
they give you feedback you can make the
changes and then they lock in the rating
so that
once it's approved they will never flip
yellow
which is fantastic so we actually
always we have a hunt we've always hit
our deadline this is the first time we
didn't hit our deadline
why is that i think they just took a
while getting back to it it was just
running
slow the other day and just fine and we
went through multiple rounds of
corrections right
yeah we were talking about uh some
sensitive sticky stuff
so that episode is up and thank you to
all of our members by the way we love
you so much
thank you thank you thank you but anyway
we're posting it
publicly for everybody we just got
approval this morning
so we're posting it tomorrow saturday
with peace and love we are posting the
episode on
saturday tomorrow with peace and love
peace and love
peace and love um today's episode is
sponsored by
loving the good mythical morning uh cup
you got there
oh yeah i stole this when we were there
we did what did we just they gave us a
gift basket
yeah dude that's my favorite thing when
we both have it and i'm like
so we're like bizarro good mythical
morning let's talk about that
uh i'm definitely rat link is like more
put together
i'm definitely link red is kind of a
mess
i'm definitely feeling more like right
there you know those guys have their
[ __ ] together it's crazy
they have like they have like a green
room
a gift basket yeah like a handler
there's somebody there to like handle
you it's crazy
i don't have it in my document thank you
to our sponsors
okay thank you to our sponsors keeps
its keeps right and upstart for
sponsoring this episode of the ac
podcast
you know thank you thank you you're
welcome rango
[Music]
yeah those guys and then what was crazy
is when we were sitting down at the desk
to do the video
they have a teleprompter you probably
know this is them but it blew my mind
that was in front of the lens
so they're reading off a teleprompter
and looking directly into the lens
that's awesome hi deck we can get one of
those if you want
what the [ __ ] do i need anymore i'm off
the rails baby
yeah what am i gonna do with the
teleprompter hello
this is the h3 podcast welcome to the h3
podcast guess what we're late
that's written you can definitely
predict that
don't you write it into the
really good one oh what's the title of
this yeah we're squashing the beef with
critical
so we had two huge youtube beefs that
massive beef
yeah huge massive beasts that were
simmering over the top the foot
soldiers were had pitchforks in hand we
were storming the capital
we were ready we were i saw such a funny
line about the capital thing
they said i no longer think that
nicholas cage stealing the
declaration of independence is
implausible
[Laughter]
i was like man that's [ __ ] true like
damn
so good oh maybe before you get started
we can say
oh somebody donated what the f they
notice me yeah 100 donations
notice me are you going to charge that
back
she actually that same person donated
200.
why what's going on i do wonder if we
should communicate to our
viewers that we don't want it to become
that kind of stream when we kind of like
just shout out donations right well
first of all let's say
thank you yes we thank you so much thank
you thank you
well it's a good one i was wondering if
we should limit the donation
cap yeah because in a way it starts to
make me feel bad yeah
i know we're going to miss some of them
because the nature of how we do it is we
have topics to talk about we don't
necessarily want to just be like
shouting out
no every usually i'll i'll read a
donation if it's just like an
interesting comment or conversation
start or something
that's the instructions the guys have
thank you thank you for that hundred
dollar donation what did she say the
first time what did she what did she
want to say
i haven't seen the president it says
somebody read it yeah it it
says that she uh is a cam girl
who wears teddy fresh on cam and she's
being canceled
on twitter and villainized in her
community much like trisha
love you guys over what what's her name
i'm interested
uh if you're in the discord uh dot nil
reb uh
dm uh zack you're sorry i want to see
first of all
what's her name dot mil reb
it's nil red i don't know if that's what
she goes by on only
what do you do to get canceled on only
fans here's dot
no reb somebody look up the dot nil rep
drama and and
tell me if you can tell me if there's
some dot no rev drama because i i'm
interested for sure
someone posted the question um in a
donation
i don't see dot no rib though but go
ahead yellow ethan i had a friend in
high school who told me
she thought everyone ate while pooping
she did it with a cheeseburger most
recently she also she's
burger the ocean both as an adult
do you think either is normal okay
eating on the
toilet on one hand that's a big note for
me
okay eating on the toilet sometimes i've
i've done it but i don't think it's
normal i mean
like i've like let's say if i'm
finishing something
if you're finishing let's say let's say
i'm on the lab yeah let's say i'm on the
last
half the back half of a pizza slice and
then i got gotta take a dump
i'll bring it with me but bringing a
whole cheeseburger in there
is is pretty barbaric i think both are
pretty barbaric
i think in general you should not bring
food into the
bathroom hey it's all part of the
process of life in one whole out the
other
no i think it's a golden rule
so wait what was the other question wait
is this person you you don't have this
friend this is you
that's fine it's definitely you but what
was the other question pooping in the
ocean
oh that is what wait what's the context
of that
you're not a fish i know people say
little fish poop in the sea
yeah they're [ __ ] living the sea
they're poop is supposed to be in the
ocean the human
turds is not supposed to be in the ocean
you absolutely [ __ ] freak
what are you talking about are you
talking about your deep sea fishing and
you plop one overboard
because that's what happens when you sit
on them no detail they just ask do you
think either is normal
it depends are you talking about like
you're at the beach and you go in and
just [ __ ]
that's what i eat because there's people
there for christ's sake
but if you're like deep sea then i guess
it's normal
i mean i would use a toilet
like civilized people deeper
i need more details i think
[Laughter]
uh so dot nil rip
with this she is she really because i
searched dot never but i didn't see
anything let's just start youtube name
again i don't but i had like seven
subscribers i i don't know
because i'm wondering
does anyone give oh here zac's
of course found it i'm not the only fans
expert
okay here we go she only has 13
followers what is she being cancelled
for
i she didn't really specify in the
message i don't know what the f
okay well i find this story odd and i
wish you i don't know how you can get
cancelled with 12 people following you
to be honest
maybe that's just i don't know
well if you're first of all to be can't
the idea of being canceled means that
enough people know about you
to look to like get cancelled in
personal life is that what she means i i
have no idea
i don't know how you get canceled with
12 followers on twitter but god bless
i wish you all the best all right i'm
interested though
so anyway i was talking about this is a
lot of activity in the donations i don't
know how to go ahead let's read it if
they're interesting stuff let's go
well some of it is well hold on somebody
maybe we
we got to figure this out yeah we're
good you're supposed to be on donations
right you're reading donations
yeah i have them i just don't know when
to interrupt you guys always interrupt
always interrupt well we're talking
about it now so now it's a good time to
shout it out
yeah i mean a lot of them are about uh
how people want
shout outs but um okay i sent one right
now on the discord where's for
attendance
shout out to peace and love with peace
and love
if you donate for a shout out you will
not be read
peace and love it almost looks like i'm
warning you with peace and love
mourning you with peace and love your
shoutouts will not be read
questions for dan and ethan dan what's
your favorite king
gizzard song and ethan what's your
favorite grateful dead song i don't like
these i don't like this question with
peace and
love this is not this is not
a good question for the podcast with
peace and love
how do i convey what constitutes a good
question or not
but i think like conversation starters
yeah or continuation if we talk about a
topic and you have an opinion about it
i think generally speaking if you're
asking what's my favorite anything with
peace and love it's probably not a good
question for the podcast
right also it's my birthday today can
you please
no no with peace and love no birthday
wishes
on the podcast i'm warning you with
peace and love
stop any birthday wishes will be ignored
thank you
thank you thank you i have a separate
doc right i'm copying the donations as
they go through but yeah most of them
aren't conversation starters that's why
i don't interrupt okay okay
thank you thank you so anyway as i was
saying
what the f was that this game was kind
of coke
oh my god it's the best sound bite why
is he whispering it
sounds like he's getting heavy jesus oh
jesus oh jesus okay
jesus uh so
as i was saying we are squashing the
beef
with some of our biggest longtime
youtube rivals
uh this could have exploded this could
have turned
really ugly but just like joe biden we
are
what does he say we are turning down the
rhetoric
we are
[Music]
so first of all
d'angelo who's calling in today around
one o'clock
uh we're squash we had a huge beef with
d'angelo who made a
video attacking frenemies viciously no
i'm kidding it was nice
but uh in his
in his videos he um
well we we went over it but you know i i
contacted him i said hey let's do a call
on the podcast
and he put me in and he gave me an email
that i forwarded to dan
right and then it was his man i thought
he was giving me his email but it was
his manager
i was like oh i got big times by
d'angelo
funnily enough i gave him i gave it to
dan so we had people
talking we had people talking big time
him yeah
you both big time to each other i feel
like my big time was more justified
because
this is a podcast and you're the
producer but he's but you know what i
mean
he's i'm a god guy he's got a manager
dude d'angelo's kind of a big deal you
guys
it's awesome i never understood what a
manager
for a youtuber means i gotta ask him
what does it mean maybe it's just his
friend maybe it's just him
maybe it's just another alias for him i
know people that do that they set up
like a manager alias and it's just them
that's smart
it is kind of good it's kind of good it
has a degree of separation didn't trump
trump used to do stuff like that oh yeah
john barron was his uh yeah pseudonym
that he was oh
that was what the twitter meme on yeah
that's why there was all these accounts
popping up
i didn't realize okay that's fine
i had to beat off yeah he used to call
in as his own publicist and it was
obviously him
weird weird baby wasn't the name for the
stormy daniel [ __ ] too
wasn't it john barron i don't know
that's what i'm saying he used that name
for a lot of
like it was his alter ego or is his
alter ego
love it i love it
i love it so and anyway he big-timed me
i big time
we have people talking to people someone
keeps saying that i'm pregnant i gotta
tell you i'm not who's saying that why
would they say that
i wish we're trying we're trying it's
not happening
i mean it's just it's kind of a good bet
to just
guess that she's pregnant at any time
since we're trying you know what i mean
the universe so far is not wanting it to
happen
since we had theodore i want more kids
now i thought maybe two but now i want
three
i want five kids
i want seven kids but trust me as soon
as it happens we'll tell you
like last time we didn't even wait we we
like people usually wait the three
months
because you may have a miscarriage i
single-handedly disapprove of the bad
luck vodka is like
as soon as we find out well people say
it's bad luck but i we
disprove that bad luck it's stupid it's
just that they don't want to have to
tell you when you have a miscarriage but
i think that's stupid too because so
many people have miscarriages
people should know that happens spitting
facts queen
right my queen do spit
facts though so not pregnant
but we are trying we're about to start
this now we
ila specifically is about to start this
medicine that like
medicine i have i have a procedure to do
right i didn't know if you wanted to
talk about that i was talking about the
medicine you'll take afterwards
well first i gotta do a procedure you
want to tell them about the procedure
i have uh polyps i don't even know what
it means but i gotta take them out
they just scrape them off apparently
it's not a big deal right
i think so like plaque like going to the
vagina vagina dentist
yeah and then once that's done
then you take this medicine that like
rapid fire blasts your eggs out
like buck shot instead of one egg it's
like a buck shot
which interestingly when you do that it
increases the chance of having
twins as well right which could be wild
but hey
you know what would be cool it it it's
kind of cool because you're like okay
that two for one you know yeah
there's like i guess that's the
advantage of having two for one let's
[ __ ]
go you know i don't have to go do this
again
right i mean that whole nine month
process is pretty grueling
at times so
it's like a cheat code that is by the
way next friday and we're going to need
to discuss
what to do with after dark but we can
talk oh because
right hmm well obviously nothing comes
you know nothing
stops after dark so you're going to have
to look at yourself i'm kidding
i'm coming
so anyway i was talking about the
d'angelo um
so he big time me and then he called
actually he called out the crew members
quite a bit a b
you got called out big time from
d'angelo
hear them he peed through i mean yeah
he was throwing stones here you know
exposing shaolin lester he was like the
first one to do it and then
she threatened him just for context he's
we're reacting to him he's reacting to
us and now i'm reacting to him reacting
to us we're directing
the
okay i like him i'm not going to warm up
somebody in the chat says um he he sided
with you and was defending you during
the
james charles hoodie
definitely didn't happen this is the
second fact they gave him that's just
not true shalom lester never hit me with
a lawsuit
literally i never made a public comment
i about the um well now i want to know
what he thinks about the hoodie
yeah so if i may
he said if you may simp go ahead he said
that literally we didn't know
what we were talking about we gave him
uh wrong information
dan clearly said he was just reading a
donation
and uh he did i was just going off the
cuff and i don't know anything i'm just
i'm just reading what's in front of me
and so i have his video down here on
shannon lester
where he said that sean lester was
taking uh threatening him with legal
action
that she was going to make a police
report and threaten him with legal
action
so we weren't wrong you were close to
the truth
you squirted up i guess his point is
that it never happened
right i said threatened though you did
say threaten huh well
what do we what are we splitting hairs
here for
easy but okay do some research but
actually the the
purpose he's calling is because um
as i've said this is a pro shane podcast
previously
but i watched his whole series his whole
tati
shame yeah we both did and uh jeffrey
series which was fantastic i have to say
that guy brought the mother
loving receipts we actually had nothing
to watch that night and we ended up just
watching all of them
i think i watched all of his like he's
good his essays
but the shane one was brutal it was like
holy [ __ ] like
when i when just when i thought it
couldn't get worse this guy comes out
with like
the cr all this crazy [ __ ] man i was
blown away by that
but you want to talk to him about it you
know
the girl did clarify she said that
twitter was made by someone else trying
to cancel me i don't have twitter
because of the hate
oh can i call in to explain there's
before you call
in i need more backstory well you guys
can get the back yeah you guys get the
back you gotta
reach out to zach cause that's the
biggest keeper of the call
with peace and love i don't wanna be
trapped in a call with you before i even
know
if it's interesting or not you know what
i mean with peace and love
warning you with peace there's nothing
worse than when you get a call for
someone and then you realize it's not
interesting and
you don't want to be rude and hang up
but you're like oh brother
yeah we won't know what's the drama also
zach does she have a popular
um only fans like what's is she in the
top
echelon i will look into it
okay you know what i'm about to have a
diva moment
what
[Music]
i won't say it i'm being theatrical i'm
not actually like angry
i don't i'm just having to
dead air anyway um
he's gonna call in
and then our uh should we just have him
because he's that's in like 13 minutes i
don't want to go into the next story
necessarily
true and we're gonna have to do the ad
reads right before uh he calls in so um
there is a lot going on in the chat i
don't know there's a lot of activity
yeah what are they saying
maybe well a good quarter of it's about
shoe nice
oh he's all up in the chat right now
is surely causing trouble no he's been
he's being
very good he's behaving himself okay
good good don't blow up our chat shoot
don't make me
she said she's not on only fans so what
did she say
you know what what is the story with
this girl
what who are you why are people
canceling you you don't have an online
fans you don't have a twitter
you said what am i missing is a cam girl
zach bring me information don't just say
she's not on only fans i want the story
man this is all she gave me that's
literally i don't know
i don't have only fish girl you wanted
my attention i'm here i'm
begging you for details that's literally
all she's saying
all right i'm skipping it you're ca you
know what not only are you canceled on
the internet you canceled by me
podcast you're cancelled oh no i have a
comment from shoenice um
anyone ever poop out a pine cone
uh no no did he assuming that's what you
were asking
somebody donate 100 said how's the
weight loss journey ethan
oh petty 100
it's good i mean i've been exercising
every night i've been every day
every night i get on the i get on the
treadmill by the way this treadmill was
one of the best investments for me
as i i'm walking for like an hour plus
and playing
video games it's kind of epic i have my
controller
i'm walk i'm walking and playing
i already beat the demon souls remake
mastered it
slammed it destroyed it and now i
went back and i'm playing dark souls 1
which by the way at this point in the
game i'm pretty much
invincible like the four kings
that's apparently a hard fight dan it's
a decent challenge
i popped down there i literally just
tanked him through everything
and one shot him i mean i didn't die you
have lost your sleeping schedule
completely i know it's such a [ __ ]
mess this is bad
but can you be are you can you believe
that dan i can believe it i mean you're
doing the me
if anybody's familiar with dark souls
ethan literally did the meme build
without even realizing it
he's got the giant dad build so anybody
that knows uh
and you're kind of a giant dad i'm a
giant dad
so i gotta say when you when you pitch
that idea of the
treadmill and the playing video games
while you walk out
i didn't i thought that was stupid i
didn't think you would actually do it
oh [ __ ] and it's all like well last
night we were watching this netflix
documentary about
night stalker pretty good by the way
very disturbing it's a new
uh very disturbing man that guy was a
sick mother
netflix yeah it's great dude
oh look at that ethan's hair i just saw
that too
okay so ethan keeps thinking that he has
to wear a beanie because his hair
doesn't look good and i don't get that
it's just
it looks disheveled
well why don't you fill me in
i tell you your hair's great all the
time what about where's my compliments
we were all complimenting you this
morning well after we already
does that that's hot so what did she say
i saw
her do an update let's get to obama
we've spent too much on this girl
she says she's top 50 of cam something
my free cam why is she being canceled
that's all i
just want this story she doesn't have
[ __ ] she doesn't have [ __ ]
it's so stupid so much part of the show
expert of why she's canceled it it's not
really
you know tell me and now i'm in too deep
you tell me why she's canceled and i'll
be in the discord
i'm not i can't move on tell me ian open
the discord there's a thing right
okay thank you ian come in with facts
don't [ __ ] help
what is this constant subtle backhanded
compliments to elevate themselves over
what like one time what the expose
account was posting it's just stuff like
this
one time calling me their realistic
goals unlike what does this mean
unlike other models they do not care
offering meetups and giving away phone
number out easily as if to show they're
different from other models oh my god
do you really think that we can relate
to this
this is like cam girl drama
offering to have both of us meet up with
one of my highest tippers who lives in
ca and stays in my house without ever
asking me what are you talking about
cam girl drama
don't meet with your biggest tippers
trust me
she's saying she's being canceled
because she has borderline personality
disorder
ah okay
i can't speak on that yeah we're gonna
stop in the chat stop with peace and
love no one cares
so we're gonna move on thank you got
deangelo in the lobby yet or look we
we had to check yeah let's get d'angelo
on the line eh all right let's do this
exactly at one o'clock get it he's such
a big time
well you know that was but for my
instructions but like
what he's not flexible at all he's like
well i just told him it was a live show
we're going to bring him in at one
o'clock so
right away and ask him to be flexible
he's punctual unlike some people
let's not spread misinformation here
let's do some copy while we wait for
d'angelo and then we could squash the
beef
then we move on to charlie who we swash
the beef with
as well which is fantastic we're we're
tenderizing
we're tenderizing i i i have to say i'm
very happy with critical
i feel good i feel happy i feel that
we might be able to give him a grace
foot rating on wiki feet
after watching his video which people do
he did complain that we
tanked his rating he was a little sad
about it so it was funny though
and he did kind of you know bow to the
king baby you kissed the ring a little
bit on that
that's all or the he kissed the um the
foot ring
how do you feel about fit foot jewelry
eva i hate it
yeah i'm not a fan of foot rings i hate
it
absolutely i hate it it's like it's i
want to smell feet
like i never said that
[Laughter]
like let's say an ankle bracelet okay
yeah
once you get beyond the ankle insanity
toe
ring it's like you're really forcing
that [ __ ] like you like jewelry
but let's be honest the toe does not
need a ring
no it looks ridiculous too like imagine
trying to put a ring on a toe
it's like it's just not it's just not
right no
no bruh no all right let's do it i want
to smell feet guys we're going to read
the copy and then d'angelo is going to
uh
join us right that's correct okay let's
start with
up starts up starts
up starts oh nice
you know that credit card the one you're
afraid to look at
as to see what the balance is if you've
been avoiding paying your debt off
it's time to confront it upstart can
help you
face and finally pay it off
alright upstart is the fast and easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses
over half of a million people use up
start to get a simple
fixed monthly payment upstart finds
smarter rates with trusted partners
because they because they ask assess
more than just your credit score with a
five minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans for more for
from one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars did that make sense i was
reading it i was kind of messing up a
lot
so i'll read that line again with a five
minute online rate check you can see
your rate
up front that's the name of the company
oh [ __ ]
maybe it should be up front it's upstart
to be very clear
with a five minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front
for loans from one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars
they're gonna give one of you guys fifty
thousand dollars alone it's a bad idea
i'm just saying i'm just generous
you can get approved the same day and
can receive
funds dan's doing this to me
that's the problem with doing these live
is that you can't
you can't redo it but it's okay
that's the nature of the beast we're
having fun out here uh
you can get approved the same day and
can receive funds as fast as one
business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start
with up start find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to
upstart.com h3 that's upstart.com
h3 don't forget to use our url to let
them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
go to upstart.com h3
[Applause]
all right next up is keeps
this hair stuff is amazing this is for
keeping your hair
it just i always think of the the
seinfeld episode where george costanza
was trying to cure his baldness and he
got the weird cream from china and it
smelled
yeah and like
it's happening people are keeping their
hair now look at these before and afters
i don't want to show the copy but i mean
i'm going to read it but
this is apparently real real photos
look at that [ __ ] before six month
difference
look at this whoa dude that guy
that guy scored big time with keeps you
know what i mean
that's wild look at this guy dude it's
beautiful
that's really i gotta say i'm impressed
yeah me too
five months keeps your hair
so that's the real deal folks
all right let me tell you a little bit
about keeps
[Music]
listen much of our identity is wrapped
up in our hair
we don't love it it's just the way it is
look at me people are
fawning over my hair they are throwing
themselves at me
worshiping my hair right
all the comments about how good my hair
looks i don't choose to have
fabulous hair it's just the way it is
sorry to be flexing on you guys you need
this medicine
from now i feel i'm sorry it's
insensitive to be flexing on them right
now
no good
i can tell i'm [ __ ] up the coppery
because everybody's just like
come on we're having fun from how it
feels after getting a fresh cut to the
way it's perfectly styled before going
out that's why
when we get into our 20s and 30s and
start noticing the first sign of hair
loss it definitely feels like panic
i feel like i just read that but i
didn't understand anything i read
you know when you do that
okay let me read that again because i
feel like did it make sense because i
like totally zoned out as
okay as guys so much of our identity is
wrapped up in our hair
and how it feels after getting a fresh
cut
that's why when we get into our 20s and
30s we start noticing the first signs of
hair loss it definitely feels like panic
time folks
because let's face it no guy's ever
ready to go bald thankfully now there's
keeps the simple and easy way to keep
your hair
[Music]
hmm you used to go to the doctor's
office to get hair loss prescriptions
now with keeps you can visit a doctor
online and get hair loss medicine
delivered right to your door
that makes it easy and deliver your
medicine every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor visits
boom this is fda approved hair loss
products
you have maybe tried them before but
never for this price
the prevention is key keep treat keeps
treats
keep keep keep keeps keep
treatments typically take between four
to six months to see results so it's
important to act fast
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you'll save
found out why keeps has five star
reviews more than any of its competitors
and more than 100
000 min trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medicine
keeps treatment start at just 10 a month
plus a limited time you can get your
first month for free
boo mother efforts
yadda yadda host must uh voice
offer let's do that where's the offer
where's the offer guys
call to action if you're ready to take
action to prevent here let's go to
keeps.com
h3 to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's
k e e p s dot com
slash h3 host must spell out website
keeps.com at least once
all right that was brutal huh
good though i feel like it was good i
mean if people want either of those
you know if people want either those
products they've got all the information
they need
yep right uh well d'angelo is in the
waiting room showing okay
good perfect title let's break about
stand by
letting him in now i closed my
documental accident
[ __ ] and he
is coming in right
there's a link to it in this clip i got
it thank you
i see him hello oh i hear him there he
is
hi do you see us yeah y'all look
fantastic peace and love you look
fantastic too
here let me pin your video so i don't
see all these goofballs actually can you
pin him down or do i need to do that
uh you can put it on your computer
um whoops here i i can do it d'angelo
let's go d'angelo hello hello hello
yes how are you my dude i'm doing fine
just you know boring youtube stuff the
website's acting super weird
so i couldn't get a video up today so
now i don't know what to do with myself
um those youtube dramas so
oh so first of all d'angelo did not
appreciate being called a drama channel
and that's not what i said oh okay well
this is a good question
but he made a good point ela he said
we're as much drama as he is and i agree
right you don't consider yourself a
drama channel right
i i don't know i try not to be too
touchy about it
it's a derogatory it is what it is right
yeah
i kind of learned to deal with um that
it is what it is
approach withdrawal at some point i
thought we weren't drama but were you i
was like oh my god we're drama channels
well it is what it is
right no i just try to have fun so
okay we have some first of all we're
squashing our beef right now okay
do you want to cross do you want to
maybe put show your feet so we can get
you on wiki feed or no
um we would have to wait i don't i'm not
like
mentally there yet we have to do it the
right way
we can't hopefully i just wanted to give
you that opportunity
because we have such a powerful wikifoot
bump that you'll probably be number two
on the website if you did that but
that's like hungry not to force you not
to force you you know i want to pray
no i know who to call now yeah yeah yeah
yeah probably won't be soon
probably won't be too long okay good
that's nice to hear
um what is so also i noticed um
so you gave me your email it was your
manager's email i feel like you big time
to me a little bit did you big time me
no no i just i
try not to read emails my manager takes
care of all that
because my problem is when i scroll
through my own email
i tend to say yes to everything um which
is
not good because people come in with
like the craziest offers
so instead my manager just looks at all
of that stuff in here
he's like does your emails i love that
way better at handling
those kind of things because if you guys
have left this to me i would not be here
right now
my time management skills are not not on
the same level as you guys you have like
a well-oiled machine
well thank you very much we started 25
minutes late today
yeah well the wall wasn't 25 well yeah
because it was 12
10. it wasn't 25 15.
let's not bicker in front of d'angelo he
thinks we have a well-oiled machine
take it take it all right so
a b actually uh has beef abe
do you want to do earlier yeah he says
abc
well he wanted to defend himself a
little bit a b oh if you want to
maybe discuss that i said i'm a fan of
that
d'angelo has the beef he said he has a
beef with me just
a beef hey beef
well you know so okay what this is
stupid who cares
i want to talk about the shane thing
same so the shane thing was um
by the way we loved watching your videos
oh yeah we went on a marathon
i watched all three i watched the shane
i watched the jeffrey i watched the tati
yeah i watched the blaire white
and i watched the um wait oh yeah
you didn't watch the white yeah i went
on either went to bed and i kept
watching
stay up all night
yeah passive aggressive
um so okay the shane thing yeah
there's so much disturbing behavior in
there
it's really bizarre really it's true i
didn't there so i knew a lot of it but
actually your video had even more
than what i knew about is shane just
like
the chances are i don't know anything
about shane so i'm just going off the
cuff here but
my take on shane is that he's a
obviously a disturbed person who is
probably traumatized as a child
through some kind of abuse which is
probably the reason why he doesn't know
how to tell what's appropriate way to
interact and joke about sexual things
and that's that's how i see that yeah
and not to excuse his behavior right but
i just that's how i
see it so i don't know what's the
solution with shane in your opinion
is he can he ever come back to youtube
or like what do we do what
what tell me what to think about shane
it certainly raises a lot of questions
in terms of when you have creators who
don't set boundaries for themselves
but then they kind of get this giant
platform like whose job
is it necessarily to set that boundary
definitely not mine
definitely not yours we don't have the
power youtube has done what it's done
they even did take some of their own
action
at one point temporarily demonetizing
him but as far as whether or not he
should come back
i mean from a business standpoint
this is where he is you know um
logically i'm sure he'll be back at some
point throughout the year
i mean at that point i won't have
anything to do with it
but i think it just it raised a lot of
questions about
how much people are willing to put aside
in order to watch you know their
favorite creator if you will
but as for like where do we draw the
line i don't know because all i can do
is really just
draw attention to things you know what i
mean i can't i'm certainly no arbitrator
nor do i try to be well i have to say i
was super impressed with the quality of
your video and the depth of research i
thought was
freaking phenomenal and the way that you
presented it was was super good
so i do think the praise is warranted i
think the hype is warranted with
d'angelo wallace and i recommend that
shane video you know it's like
i knew about like the weird
sexualization with kids yeah we've
talked about
a lot of it ourselves on the on our
podcast a while ago but
still watching your whole video kind of
put it in a
deeper perspective because you did have
more than we knew of
and seeing it all together well dude
there was like the animal stuff
when i saw all that put together i was
like holy smokes
the animal stuff was really weird to me
i'm one of the people to be quite frank
that always believed that cats story
it's just way too detailed it's just way
too detailed
and when he's telling that story it's
not he's not kidding
i think he [ __ ] on his cat comments
certainly no more comments than i've
given in that video
i just i try not i try not to waste
people's time i definitely understand
like the image that i'm putting forth on
youtube a lot of it
at first glance just seems very
inflammatory very long
so i figure if if people
per chance click into the videos
hopefully i'll give them something
that's actually worth watching you know
what i mean
because at the end of the day this is my
job there is a certain way to do it
in order to maximize clicks but i don't
think that means you have to waste
people's time per se so i do i try to
structure my videos in a way where if
you come then you're getting the
information
things that you can actually back up and
things are not just speculation
and so they certainly do take like a
little longer to make i certainly wind
up being late
to a lot of situations because of that
but i just it's the way
i enjoy creating that sort of long-form
content
chat is saying the interview is going to
end for enemies i disagree
i don't think so yeah they're saying
this is going to in front of me that's
what people are saying in the chat
look the shane topic is just really
complicated
jesus is um obviously we met him in
person when we did the podcast it was
nice it was never not nice to us
but um all the stuff that are
pointed out about him are definitely
things worth talking about because it
does have a big platform and
i think if anything it's really
important that he gets
to come to terms with his issues and
work on them
i don't i don't think anyone should be
just canceled to oblivion and not be
able to work on himself and
see where things go you know the i don't
think that's a healthy approach for
anyone
well like i said my i speculate that it
comes from a place of deep
trauma in his own life i know he's
hinted that he's been
abused right as a child but i don't
think he's ever specifically
said so it's tough it is a tough
situation you know
like when you compare shane to someone
like let's just say chris delia who also
got canceled last year
like shane correct me if i'm wrong but
when i say something like
shane didn't necessarily
well i guess it's not necessary when i
say shane didn't really do
he he there was like victimless crimes
you know what i mean but
but what would you say to that if i said
well shane
shane is just kind of perverted but he's
it's more about like didn't really
inappropriate stuff um
done on video and i think it's like what
you said that he has no
he doesn't understand what's appropriate
or not appropriate well would you say
that shane doesn't have any victims do
you think that's a
appropriate uh description
from a legal standpoint unlike unlike
um a lot of other creators there's
certainly nothing there and i even made
sure
to um specify in that video you know i'm
not accusing him of any crimes or
anything like that
as far as people just being affected by
what he was doing in a
negative way there are certainly people
who have said that's their experience
with that
i mean it's not something i have
experience with but you would really
have to ask the people
you know saying that what's your story
you're like us
you're like a smart eloquent guy
are you in college are you out of
college what's the deal with you
oh i graduated in um 2019 at
our lady of lake university it was a fun
time
are you well people were trying to
speculate if you're married or single
yeah
i am not married not at the moment
anyway
who knows it's all subject to change not
subject actually
i think i graduated in 2018. i don't
know why i just said 2019.
i don't know where that came from but
you were close
i was i was going to get there
eventually what did you major in
mass communication with a concentration
in digital film and television
production
perfection that's awesome so
how old are you you grew up watching
youtube i'm assuming you're of that age
yeah i'm 22. yeah i grew up
watching i wouldn't say i grew up
watching youtube but in my
teens that's definitely when i got super
into it i was introduced to all these
people
i was like holy crap you can upload
videos to a website and this can be your
job
you can get rich from this kind of thing
a lot of your videos i was watching at
that time as well so
it's all pretty exciting stuff so
that shane video was kind of like a big
turning point i remember you said you
went from like 10 000 to a million
subscribers in that one year is that
right
um it was somewhere like that was 2020
right so
somewhere along like 300k to 1.5 million
or something like that
damn yeah it was certainly certainly a
big jump
um it definitely put it definitely
changed a lot of the way that i had to
approach my videos in the future
because i think when you have you know
when you don't have to answer to as many
people
maybe you can get away with a few
mistakes here and there but now i really
look at my content
as like if i'm putting this out and this
many people can potentially be viewing
it
i have to make sure that i'm not putting
things out that i'm going to wind up
regretting or things that can be easily
disproven
or anything like that so i just think
the main thing is it just motivates me
to try even harder i think with my
long-form content
now my shorter videos are just for fun i
don't i definitely don't
care about those as much but yeah that's
the main thing i would say that changed
that's awesome yeah you're definitely a
high quality
content creator man there's not many
people on youtube these days i can
actually watch their
especially an hour long video so i
appreciate that
so jeffrey stars oh my god
the jeffree star video was great you
know
i still don't know what to make of that
guy to be honest with you
i definitely don't know especially not
with 2021 starting off
with rumors of jeffree star and kanye
doing whatever the heck they're doing
those rumors people were asking me for
my take on that as well too because i
guess
i accidentally became the jeffree star
guy yeah and i was like listen
i don't fault you for asking but in 2021
there's like
a list of people who i'm working really
hard to not
give any mental space and coincidentally
jeffree star and kanye west are both
very close to the top of that list so
when i saw them coincide i was like this
is a sign
i was surprised at jeffree star's
background i had no idea because
i feel like i didn't even know about him
before and i kind of just
started to hear about him just like with
all the
makeup drama so i i only knew him as
like the makeup person
but i his background is pretty wild he
is he really came
it's sad that i um it's sad that the
video wound up being what it is just
because of his pattern of behavior
but beyond all that there really is like
a rag storage's story he's come
very far while being himself and i was
like
why can't that you know be your biggest
your biggest attribute but instead we
get
all the crazy stuff that wound up in my
video yeah
dude the theory about him um
fake that big makeup heist that was like
all over the news
it makes so much sense your theory right
and it is just a theory
just your speculation just to cover our
asses
but it makes so much sense like why
would anybody steal
makeup and then try to sell stolen
makeup like
but also something like that like a
heist phone an action movie with
right they come from the top window just
to steal some like lip
line lip gloss or something through the
laser beam
so just to feel you guys deangelo
speculated that jeffrey's whole
you guys might remember when it was huge
in the news all over this
everywhere that he had like millions of
dollars of makeup stolen
and the story was always a little bit
fishy to me but d'angelo speculates that
he faked it
in order to hype up his next release
which would be crazy because i would
never even consider that someone would
do something like that
well it were i mean also props to him i
also i do think it's probably
it's definitely fraud you can't just
can you just say that your [ __ ] was
stolen i don't know i don't think you
should be able to i don't know
it's weird that the media ate it up so
much but
it's something that i i try to be
careful of myself because
one of the things i realized is when you
have enough followers people will just
take what you're saying as fact
without looking into it themselves and
it's like
it's a double-edged sword most certainly
on the one hand
i guess you could say that's a good
thing but on the other hand i get scared
sometimes because
i even see myself like implying things
in videos or me not being clear
about things and then people just
running with it
and i can't then say well hey you know
this is
your fault for doing this i have to
recognize oh snap
i have a track record i can see why
people are just taking this at
face value so even at that i understand
why he would just say this happened in a
video with no evidence
because it makes more sense to believe
that i think than to disbelieve that
yeah so i understand why it was like
never question
but because when i was writing that
video i was already in the frame of mind
of questioning like
everything and i wanted to back up
everything when i started running into
what in my opinion was zero proof of
this actually happening
i was like oh my gosh is there actually
nothing here
and so i just left it very open-ended i
was like of course i cannot prove
that something did not happen that's
much more difficult to prove
than something happening but at the same
time i wanted to pose the question like
how much can we really believe you know
what i mean yeah
there's a there's crates of concealer
somewhere we demand answers
right no but either way
the thing about that too is whether it
was real or not which of course we'll
never have the answer
you cannot deny that the promo it caused
was
far more yeah for sure
i remember i watched that whole video
and i don't follow anything jeffree star
it was like trending it was fun you know
you know what's so crazy we have a teddy
fresh release coming out
um next week and like someone broke into
our warehouse and stole
like half of the [ __ ] and i'm just
saying
to all the news outlets watching it was
crazy there was a shootout too
there was a shootout somebody died but
anyway we got rid of the body but the
clothes are gone that's the most
important thing
teddy fresh capital raid i was there by
the way live streaming it
oh you were live streaming too the teddy
fresh capital raid yes i took charge on
them
well d'angelo i'm looking forward to
your next uh
content i will be watching it i'm a fan
yeah oh thank you
i hope so yeah it's gonna be pretty
great pretty great and you guys oh wait
okay fun fact
if i can just throw a little spoiler
there the video is about
kovid 19 and you guys are actually
heralded as a very positive example yes
i knew i loved you i loved d'angelo i
knew that this guy was the best creator
on youtube yeah
with a few channels who are always like
testing
at the one point when some of your crew
members got covered they were separated
you guys were just making sure
everything's right
through all the tests and i'm like okay
if the h3 can do it
i tr nobody nobody else has an excuse
clearly you can continue running a big
show with a bunch of people
i don't have to pretend well we moved
our whole operation to our basement
because we didn't want to be in a small
space together when
we've been in our freaking basement for
like almost a year now
i get frustrated with other people
though who are not being safe
and are not being honest with their
followers i am so down to watch that
video because
there are so many creators that are just
so [ __ ] irresponsible have you seen
the video of when tanner fox calls logan
paul and jake paul
no oh bro i'll still wait was it the one
where he said i have covered and he's
like oh i don't care
yeah we don't care
so jake paul first of all he has a
podcast with guests
he sits right across from guests and he
man it's like literally tanner calls
logan he goes i don't give a [ __ ] but
thanks for letting me know and then you
proceed to do a podcast with
people in person yeah yeah we have the
sound bites i don't know if you can hear
our sound bites go ahead they can
they're fantastic
so that's jake go ahead play jake
i
and then play the guy screaming in the
background of the j call
we don't care that was his friend in the
background
there's a tan there's a tana mojo clip
as well that might be a great sound bite
where her and her friend are like we
don't effing care and they claim that
that was not about
exactly that sound bite i you know it
wasn't clear enough audio because it was
we tried
now d'angelo just if you want to sing my
praises even more i'm just going to let
you i'll just bring you in maybe give
you some intel
back when kovid's start was starting to
peek out i made a whole podcast about it
when people said i was being an alarmist
and people were calling me a fear monger
i was back in like february and i just
want to say
that uh you know kind of a global
pandemic
yeah i just want to say i was right
oak what is that how do you feel about
frenemies
how do i feel about friend of mine he
made a whole video about it i know
but no no no no it's a good question
it's a good question
i look i was very clear in that video
that i
watched friends i did not want to frame
it as like
oh my gosh this is so bad and i don't
take part in this
and i did watch your last episode as
well let me just tell you that was
surreal i started watching it as soon as
it came out
so then we're only on episode 16
something like that
and now like i was featured in the
beginning of it
so the journey from just like a listener
to
winding up as one of the topics was so
funny so i'll take
i'll take what i can get half of the
frenemies podcast
really likes me so that works for me we
can bump it up to 100
later in the future well oh my god
i do think that the clout transfer is
complete
although i have to say you did you did
me kind of dirty you put my dms in the
thumbnail without telling me that's a
big no-no on youtube
oh yeah totally yeah i didn't just put
them in the thumbnail i
opened them on stream that was great i
was like what the [ __ ] is he doing
like i know it was all good but i was
like you can't do that
no if it was anything that made you look
any kind of bad
i would have just kept that to myself
but you're just like you're
i think that's what was throwing me off
a bit because um
i mean i was i try to be even you can't
be
even and be human but i try to be even
with all of my criticism
so i was grateful i think that you kind
of saw down the middle of it you know
what i mean
like i said about the podcast i don't
have 100 negative feelings about it i
really do believe all the things i said
in the beginning too
about it being a more realistic
portrayal of trisha and about your
friendship being real even though a lot
of people say it's fake and just about
how funny it is so i was glad that
that didn't get lost and like the
criticism at the end but i will say like
multiple sound bites
of tricia peter saying i hate dandela
wallace it's kind of iconic
that's kind of iconic yeah
unfortunately trisha will never like you
i'm afraid but yeah but
on my side of the desk we are stans
i have no criticism of you
maybe you should i try i try to be i try
to be
right now i have no criticism but i'll
tell you what the moment i have one
you'll be damn sure to hear about it
live perfect
what'd you say about the james charles
oh james charles said he said
oh yeah so you said you never publicly
defended me so do you think james
charles ripped me off
here and now live on the h3 podcast
james charles color block hoodie yes
ripoff no bro you're asking me to
sacrifice my
james charles twitter follow i'm going
to have to do some
computations is this worth it
hey you're the you spit the facts that's
it that's your own stick
all right here we go yes either james or
somebody on his design team
it was almost a 1-1
thank you you heard it here
i knew that my faith in d'angelo was not
misplaced
oh my god this is the team
what no one tell him anything so he
keeps the phone yeah nobody nobody send
this clip to
james right he'll never know sister
uh sister snatch all right deangelo i'll
let you go
thank you so much it was fun yeah it was
a great time we appreciate you we think
you're great everybody go check out his
channel
and um i actually i'm really looking
forward to that cover video it's going
to be fantastic somebody needs
to do that video so january 31st
it's my one plug i had to take it really
you're planning that you're planning to
be
like you have that specific of a
deadline
no it's just like that's the latest
possible time i can get it up
contractually because
there's a brand deal in it oh the brand
deal
okay i know that yeah
all right i'll catch you guys later
thank you so much for having me all
right take care
god bless all right all right bye
we love you matched and that was fun i'm
so happy that
we're making friends on youtube i know
the pop like we are making friends on
youtube
which is something i never really did
you know
he's d'angelo is someone that speaks
only the truth
yeah he walks the center line like
what was buddha's name siddhartha yeah
like siddhartha himself
[Laughter]
and yet even d'angelo who under
risk of being unfollowed by james
charles
said and i quote it was basically a one
for one copy
love to hear it yeah
his shane video was really okay cool
but i'm still torn on like
i'm still torn on
i personally don't think shane is a bad
person like i said like i keep saying is
i think
it's just a dude who's deeply disturbed
and traumatized
and doesn't know where the line is you
know
yeah i mean hopefully during this time
he's actually
getting to really disconnect for a
moment and just kind of like
work on his on himself
i'd like to think if he does come back
that he'll well
you know people are saying you didn't
mention the part about shane being
racist
oh right you're right i didn't yeah the
racist [ __ ] was brutal actually
i totally forgot there were so many
honestly
i think people should watch that video
it is really good there was so much
which is why i get it right try to i
totally forgot
but like yeah i mean so
the racist [ __ ] was pretty brutal he
had like he did blackface like
actually he made a really funny point in
his video he said
he did blackface more often than he did
uh um
what makeup or what was it oh yeah
because he was saying he's a beauty
he was a beauty youtuber so he has more
blackface videos than makeup videos
because he used to do it so much back in
the day also what i like that d'angelo
showed is that
um saying that that was okay at the time
like it kind of showed how that's just
not true even at that time when those
were made that was not okay
he dude he is a really pers he his
videos are
really really well put together i'm
super impressed
yeah he made a super compelling argument
that like
people used to be edgy right but people
didn't just used to wear blackface for
the sake of wearing blacklights and he
compared it for example to like
jimmy kimmel has this notorious uh bit
where he used to go
all black body and do a carl malone bit
and
the thing is like
shane's blackfaceness didn't really
contribute anything to the joke it was
literally just blackface
and also he was he he like in just kind
of like in a bad way like this yeah
like in a bad way yeah and also like he
showed back
in the day he was he would just make
like really terrible
black people jokes too it was like i was
like whoa
that's tough you see the whole picture
it's really tough
to to take it all in it's a lot
but i do feel that shane is someone who
is willing to be
as outrageous as possible to get a laugh
and i think that's what
he doesn't understand the the border
it's a great i mean watch it and decide
for yourself you know that video
definitely does deserve all the views it
has
so we have a comment from an ex-mormon i
would like to explain the magic
underwear
also have a foot fetish whoa can you
have a foot fetish as a mormon
what is that ex-mormon i wonder if he
had to decide between feet and mormon
yeah i actually thought i was going to
smell feet throughout this week
got messaged by about like five or six
mormons who are fans of the show which
big no on the magic underwear it was it
from all of them
said well the magic underwear don't do
that i knew that it was only trisha who
was like ready to show up and
apparently it's called garments trisha
wanted to show up in mormon garments aka
magic underwear to eat grilled cheese
and do trivia i was like
we cannot do that oh my god
and the mormons wrote in with resounding
no you cannot
do that what does it look like though
i'm actually i've never seen it i'm
gonna pull up a picture
mormon garments what is it used for
it's basic i think someone said it's
used for like when you go on a mission
because they go on like missions it's
really just this eh okay it's just like
conservative
looks comfortable the mormons are
stacked bro
look at this look at all that space
nice deep v and [ __ ] nice deep i mean
that's it i like it for pajamas
to wear around the house don't wear that
it's disrespectful no i'm not going to
i'm just saying it's kind of
oh yeah it's kind of baller actually
it's kind of baller
that's what i'm trying to say it is kind
of baller
so they wear it when they go on
missionary or when they go in the
temple i don't know
i really don't know what why is it like
why did they do like a sexy
version of the mormon underwear [ __ ]
anyway um so d'angelo is
off my enemies list and onto my friends
list
we're making friends
do everybody see the chat spamming uh
alan dent over and over again
i do and i have no idea what they're
talking about me neither uh
ellen dent is the guy who said let me
call in
but he's not about the mormon underwear
but he's not part of the discord
so everybody's writing for alan dent huh
oh that that was the ex-mormon was alan
that's true yes
i followed the chat sometimes because
i'm trying to it was just a wall of
alan dent and i was like what's what's
going on here yeah um
um so moving on
we have critical who
first of all the beef began when he
proclaimed himself the god of wikifeed
it was it was a critical error right
well said dan
who as you guys all all well know he is
he's not only not the god of
wikifeed he's not even close to number
one on the website that of course
that title is of course goes to yours
truly
maybe av shut up sorry
but that really pissed me off
the only reason i'm number two is
because i was the one that was reporting
the
critical situation live don't you think
it's a little
opportunistic amy that you snuck into
the the
number two spot i just explained how i
didn't say i've never
not one time i've ever said i've already
i've always said don't do it i said it
because
yeah but you know what that means don't
do it don't act all
innocent it's because i was there
reporting the uh
that's mad because his feet went up the
same day and lord knows what they say
ethan klein
oh people have been digging and finding
new feedbacks
oh evie you're not on here anymore oh
there you go
whoa they removed you huh you got bomb
sorry holy [ __ ] they removed you ab
wait zach that's weird you know what's
crazy is that through all of this they
keep me number one
the people on the website the moderators
of this website
have deemed that i shall be number one
you've done a lot for this website i put
them on the [ __ ] map yeah
you know what it was it's probably my
co-workers who did it because
ian and zach are conspiring against me
because they're mad i got that second
how do you figure ian was ian was
sending to the chat last week
dude they added so many holy crap
i wonder if this was a fan or one of
them if someone didn't think that you
were kidding
like
wait hold on this is intriguing someone
went back through
the last i checked this page like a week
ago yeah these are all new
then this was the newest pick from our
from our uh
trip for your birthday yeah and so i
want to talk about
somebody went back yeah really far i
don't even know what
what video is this from i have no idea
what the
f
and then this is yeah way back
195 boy i wish
huh man
these people are freaks oh geez
look how skinny i am cool
i'm going to be like that someday what
is this why do you look like that
what is this you can't even see my feet
it's okay because it's frames
you're moving
that's hot i could jizz to that
yo somebody said uh i could shed some
light on the mormon garments they're
actually worn as much as possible and
only removed when showering and swimming
they're worn underneath regular clothing
oh so they do wear them all the time i
like
it you guys want to learn about magic
underwear i think
what we just did oh we just did thank
you that's it that's all
you need to know i'm no foot fetishes
but i feel like you could definitely
jerk it to this
let's read the comments because there's
always funny ass comments on
a mix of like foot super troopers and
actual genuine
members of the website who are confused
someone wrote and donated a hundred
dollars
i have an amazing 2020 success story
where i lost
100 pounds in seven months and now it
needs to be shared and i know you want
to hear it too
please let me call in say what it needs
to be shared
send us some before and after pics we'll
look at it
that's amazing somebody wrote nasty
rude excuse me somebody wrote nasty
gaga86 okay
user gave me one star ugly feet [ __ ] you
gaga
blacklist user what does that do how is
it possible
here we go listen to this one star how
is it possible this man
single-handedly ruined this entire
site's rating system
it's crazy frankly what him and his
psycho fans did such a shame
it's just one person why you got to be
such a hater ass [ __ ]
is it possible that people on the
website actually just like my feet you
punk okay something is happening here
yeah that one oh well i got three stars
from them at least
nice oh my god this
looks a lot like bro you're let me look
at this profile picture before i read
this comment put slave 82. brad you got
issues dude
he didn't rape let's not judge i'm not
judged true
no judging what do you think about these
these little boys oh
bro you guys are [ __ ]
why should i derive this i'm i'm the law
these are my people
looks a lot like his fans are making
accounts just so they can give him a
five-star rating i mean this dude
currently has 6.4
he has a higher rating than sean mendes
chris hemsworth the zac efron justin
bieber
who says just because they're handsome
more handsome than me
that they have nicer feet than me
there's no logic he says your feet are
average as hell
or rightly or wrongly the undisputed
kings of wikifeed men
this guy's feet are average as hell well
not in the opinion of all the people who
raided
they're not good feet at all one star
right man stay mad haters
6.5
for five dollars he said look into the
mormon handshake that gets you into
heaven i've heard it's a big secret
oh there's a mormon handshake are they
not are we not supposed to know about
the mormon handshake
i can't tell if he's trolling or not let
me look into it no that sounds something
real mormons are up to all kinds of
tricky business
like they have all kinds of secrets they
seem overall like there's nothing bad
no they're nice dude mormons are the
nicest people ever i love dandelion
mormons oh yeah mormon handshakes real
interesting
holy [ __ ] yeah this video from youtube
says secret mormon temple handshake with
hidden camera
huh oh well we're not supposed to watch
it oh i'm watching it
why is the secret because they have
there's all kinds of secrets in the
mormon church there's like different
levels
it's kind of scientologist scientology
in that regard
i don't like that they have like secret
sanctums and stuff
and secret teachings and
and i swear to god i i know that the
truth
the church i think no longer believes
this but they
the one of the original tenets of
mormonism was that black people
are evil spirits straight up
that that's why they were black because
there are evil spirits that lost the war
and you guys i'm not wrong about that
right i hope not
i hope not
no i swear to god i swear to god they
think that
black people are evil spirits that lost
the war against angels
you say you say i swear to god and then
you say i'm not wrong about that right
i'm 99.9
i'm 99.9 on that hold on let's find the
secret handshake
sorry to all the mormon fans i'm just
intrigued
dude you guys have a mole deep in the
mormon church
you know what i mean here just you you
see what they get up to and like the
deep sanctums of the temple
they're like main churches in l.a it's
like this crazy ass looking
temple they're like what's up dog
what's going on are you good i just i
just got a message from
someone in discord who's mormon he said
yeah i would be okay talking about the
underwear but the handshake
is definitely off limits he said
watching the video you're gonna get a
lot of people mad
what can i do man it's on youtube he
said with the
black people thing there's some history
about that i believe
look at that touch bro
hang on i gotta see how this goes down
forgive me but
i gotta know about this secret handshake
they're like hey dog what's going on you
good baby give me some skin boy
just a little embrace a little dab yeah
just a handshake it's just a loving
embrace
jesus it's just oh then they touch again
they let go they touch again very gently
it's a gentle embrace so hear what
they're saying they go
there's no sound oh yeah
let's hear
[Music]
the second token of the ironic
priesthood
it has i will to the veil
heinrich
[Music]
what is that the first token of the
melchizedek priesthood
or sign of the nail right
[Music]
it's weird you guys someone said this is
how me and my weird dealers
that's the perfect convert yo it's just
doing a mormon handshake
that's a perfect handoff like yo what's
up baby
that was good love
love said it sounds like an npc
conversation in oblivion
hello be careful there sir
what is that sorry to the mormons if i'm
being insensitive but i'm very intrigued
by the secrets
hey don't be mad at me being mad at this
[ __ ] guy this guy's a rat
this guy put a camera in his robe and
went and started shaking hands and [ __ ]
this guy's a rat man
you know what i mean i'm just here for
the tease oh what's this trisha just
posted a video of why she is scared of
jeffrey
and the thumbnail looks like she's
crying oh my god trisha
okay we better watch that for this
purpose
i wonder if she's baiting us to watch it
like she's on that level these days
[Music]
she knows exactly what she's doing and
we're gonna watch it
man these guys have soft hands
[Music]
it's crazy it all goes down in the road
you guys stop spamming about army hammer
yeah i know
shut the [ __ ] up it's really hard
already to follow the chat
while i'm trying to um engage
conversation with ethan too
and not go arm and hammer isn't that a
baking soda
army hammer the story about him oh
dm's getting leaked he's like i've been
i've been trying to make sense of that
story i can't tell what's true or not
yeah
after army hammer has been accused of
being like a cannibal
and then well one of the initial people
said that they made the story up and
then other one of his ex-girlfriends
came out and said that he
he was just like abusive you know which
i don't know but
but the really scandalous part is that
he apparently like wanted to eat parts
of them
but we don't know if that's real or not
right yeah uh i was reading up on it
yesterday and it just seems like it's
still a developing story we'll follow it
maybe we'll talk about it next week
we're aware of it you don't have to spam
about it thank you
thank you with peace and love did
anybody find out about the black
the the the thing i said about black
people
ethan is right about this black
beautiful thing thank you thank you
oh until 19 1978 when god changed his
mind about us
you should watch the book of mormon it
may be a commentary musical
but they're super accurate about the
religion right oh god
god's like you know i know i've been
saying that black people are evil demons
but i changed my mind i was wrong
just gonna walk that back real quick
same thing with the four wives
i command you to take four wives um
i take it back i was raised mormon for a
while i was super anti-mormon and
resented the whole
religion i was definitely brainwashed
this all being said i'm sorry this being
said all the mormon people i've ever met
have been extremely extremely nice like
the nicest people ever
and i used to be mormon i was raised
mormon and i have so much insight
what are we going to do what are we
going to do and another person said
that he's also an ex-mormon who can
explain things
so there's a lot of ex more yeah i think
there's a huge like ex-mormon community
because it's the thing about mormons is
it's a very
tight community and they kind of like
work with each other they marry each
other they stay within each other's
community is very very tight
and so you know people have reputations
and they're
judged and concept and the rules and
everything so
it's pretty it's pretty it sounds pretty
intense
small communities it sounds awful to me
because i kind of feel like where i grew
up is kind of like a small place
and inevitably everyone just knows
everything and i just
there's no open mindedness in those kind
of communities you can't just do
whatever you want without getting looks
without it you know when i came to you
when i came to move in with you guys
when i came
you were getting dirty looks right you
people were gossiping
well it's like everyone wants to know
everything it's like none of your
business
i don't know yeah yeah either neighbors
were weird they were like peeking out
the windows kind of
yeah i have a neighbor across the street
that it's
like she's crazy she she's always
freaking out the window
looking uh so bored like if someone came
home late she's like
really hmm oh my god what are you out
this late
you want to watch this uh um trisha
crying video
uh
you don't like to speak up someone want
to vet it yeah i'm
yeah am i what is this okay like here
she's crying
let me just watch this i don't know what
this video was in the beginning
he paid for the car services so i'm like
watching the full hearing
video i posted something in my vlog
channel how i just saw like a clip of
this guy like
this is jeffrey stars like wing guy and
also his friend he took him to wyoming
like just a few days ago like they're
they're the tight group of people that
were being
so awful to me on this vegas trip a year
ago
i think watching this is so triggering
for so many reasons
something this video apparently i guess
she she got mad at jeffrey because he
was being real mean to her
yeah although i thought 2021 trisha was
pro jeffrey but i know what these
[ __ ] are
and i don't normally don't like to speak
up on them they're [ __ ]
so quiet then
that jeffrey's actually a nice person
[Music]
they take an advantage that jeffrey's
not about airing people out anymore
okay that he's not about airing people
out anymore he could
he's lucky he's a nice person how are
you gonna talk about a person
after you got in a private jet that was
paid for you didn't spend the time
okay your [ __ ] room was paid for
he paid for the [ __ ] concert to go
see mariah carey
front row i sat next to you for the food
for the restaurant there's more than
just
buying people [ __ ] you dumbass like just
because he
brought her on the trip doesn't mean he
wasn't a douche like just because he
brought her on a trip doesn't mean that
she needs to [ __ ]
get on her hands and knees and say his
praise forever like weird
world view dude yes you were such a
boring time
you were such a boring time you were so
negative such a what
boring time what are you saying who is
this guy why are you talking [ __ ] on
tricia who's this [ __ ] guy
by the way the cultures are boring i can
i'll just have i gotta intervene bro
i can tell you're a boring weirdo boring
time what is she there to entertain you
like [ __ ] this guy
i remember he even checked they're like
yo what is wrong with you girl we're
trying to make you feel better and she's
like
um we were like hey we have to leave by
nine o'clock it's seven o'clock
like i'll put trisha's awake first and
then i'll put sure oh no
if we don't have time for my i literally
will go out like this i don't care like
you know yeah
i'm perfectly fine what three
who's doing that who did that me not me
who did that
who did that wasn't me it was not me
that wasn't in the video right hold on
let me go back just to make sure it
wasn't in the video
hey we have to leave by nine o'clock
it's seven o'clock like i'll put
tricia's weight first and then i'll put
choice
oh no no if we don't have time for mine
i literally will go out like this i
don't care like you know
i'm perfectly fine
no that was today's episode she probably
had the tab open waiting for the live
stream to start and then it started in
the middle
of her recording ah trish is watching
huh
interesting hi trisha hi sister
[ __ ] you dan i do not like this guy by
the way he is such a douche but let me
hear
or nobody [ __ ] rides for my friend
if somebody can talk [ __ ] on my friend
it'll be me not this [ __ ]
come on
oh come on
oh my god that's so funny i thought it
was one of you guys
yeah we know which one you thought it
was well yeah
he's so [ __ ] lucky he does not air
this [ __ ] out
of here
you know what was the bro are you like
the trashiest person alive doing this
while you're someone's working on your
hair
like bro you're not that serious i don't
know who you are
talking [ __ ] while someone's doing your
hair like
it's people get upset when they have
something
good and then they do something stupid
what is he responding to we talked about
your skin [ __ ]
but your [ __ ] skin looks like [ __ ]
till this day
oh my god
what what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's so aggressive wait i gotta hear i
gotta hear this
we talked about your skin [ __ ] but your
[ __ ] skin looks like [ __ ] till this
day a whole year later [ __ ]
oh my god
that makes me like i almost feel like he
punched me in the face you know
this guy is is who is this person
is anybody is anybody working to
identify this man
yeah i believe he's a hairstylist i'm
not sure because she said so you guys
know just to be clear when i asked that
i'm not it's not a rhetorical question i
have three people here
yeah no i was watching before you even
started the video i'm i'm ahead of you
okay so who is he i i believe this is
the hair by jay
i'm trying to find his own hair by jay
oh
thank you who is that this guy is an
evil
[ __ ] that is just here we have his
instagram
let's find out who this [ __ ] is
this guy is
evil bro [ __ ]
you
who talks about another person like that
like if you want to criticize her as a
person that's one thing but be like
i called just i mean that's just
dude you got problems bro good
and then they do something stupid i
despise this man
we talked about your skin [ __ ] but your
[ __ ] skin looks like [ __ ] till this
day a whole year later so don't you just
admit that she's right though
you're trying to act like it's all good
but you just admit that you were talking
[ __ ] about her
and you just did it again how was you
making fun of her skin
at all that woman right there is plain
evil i've never seen anything like that
bro you're [ __ ]
here by jay i wouldn't let that guy
touch my i won't let that guy touch my
hair
i won't get i won't let that guy near me
he's like he'd be doing my hair he's
like damn your skin is [ __ ] up dude
you're ugly bro be doing my hair
nah i'm not down with this guy
how you gonna broadcast that bro you
want to talk about good hair and what in
the hell is with this bro
you just liked it i did oh [ __ ] i didn't
know i was logged in
bruh dog you are the biggest you get the
biggest douche of the
of oh brother i can't believe this guy's
real i can't people like this for real
yeah get the [ __ ] out
stupid dumb worst looking ass [ __ ]
maybe she should go on a [ __ ] diet
and get like on her [ __ ] brain
okay dude you gotta stop you gotta stop
dude you are so pathetic you're
attacking her skin
and her weight oh my god
well trisha don't feel bad he's really
just exposing himself as a rotten human
being
and funnily enough he literally just
admit
to
you just admit to what you accused them
of which is funny
yes we paid yes we bought our flight and
brought her to a show but we yes
we also made fun of her skin called her
time and she was boring
holy [ __ ] treasure i wouldn't feel bad
about not falling out of grace with
these
psychopaths holy [ __ ] and the fact that
he's talking all this smack while
someone's doing his hair it's just
it's like bro you're just a [ __ ]
hairstylist you're not that serious
so important yeah that i cannot even
stop for a moment to shoot this dumb
video
bro you you gotta have someone doing my
hair while i'm doing it
this seems because every minute of mine
is money you know i clicked this video
going in skeptical but i have to say
trisha
this is some heinous [ __ ] maybe all that
fat is [ __ ] up
her [ __ ] brain all right i don't
think you need to shed tears over this
guy though to be honest trisha he's
literal
have some respect for the woman doing
your hair just wait till she's done man
so weird oh my god oh my god i felt so
awkward
and and you know they were fat shaming
me
and you just admitted you just admit
that you were doing all those things
you really want to hang out with people
that make fun of your weight and skin
like that's not a good time dude you
literally just admit to doing that touch
me double
and i cut in pain and
they were making fun of my skin and yeah
we i thought we were friends i thought
you just admit that all that's true
i should have talked about it and all
that [ __ ] let me tell you something
let me tell you something this stupid
dumb walrus warts oh he's wait he's
watching us
he's watching instagram
if you want to watch him i got to react
to him watching him here by jay you're
you're you're going down mother no
i'm watching him right now he's not
watching us okay
yeah i have some words for her by jay
this is why i love live because you just
go to war with people as it's happening
you're one of the rudest saddest most
pathetic
people i've ever seen on the internet
you were just a rotten dude
you know what pisses me off that i
actually liked her
i actually got along with oh my god well
for someone that liked her it sounds
like you're a real [ __ ] [ __ ]
ethan the uh the foot soldiers are
rolling out
his his chat is all like h3 and uh
talk about trisha tricia's queen yeah
dude this guy trisha is queen sorry you
know but i got
this it's just giving me bad vibes i
don't like it it is
one like foot soldiers are
mounting a defense for our oh my god
i'm sorry go ahead no just funny they're
like they're all spamming him you you're
a clown
they're not effing around he's trying to
get a little upset
how do i open his send me his live feed
so i can watch it
okay i want to watch him he's a clown
send him clown emojis too much
made her feel uncomfortable was so
negative to her but afterwards [ __ ]
don't forget to say but
i got to fly to vegas because that
person paid for a [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] the fact that he bought her
a plane ticket doesn't mean
anything who cares dude is that your
whole world is just controlled by
currency and favors like dude get a
[ __ ] grip on reality
i slept in the [ __ ] room oh my
god you have
dude you are consulted with my [ __ ]
sweets
yeah yeah she can pay you back [ __ ]
yeah
perspective don't uh for this idiot i
really believe
it's actually just like setting up we
got to defend our questions
so i'm like watching the full i don't
need to watch the tricia crime but you
shouldn't cry for this guy dude he is
such
you're such a douche send me his live
stream i want to see what's popping over
there
oh sorry soldiers are in full effect
right now he's like all flustered
he's live on instagram i i don't think
you can watch
them unfortunately oh wait maybe you'll
always just wait
about the things that she was saying on
it okay
what she said was totally false
and the thing that upset me was that
these things were being said
right sorry right these things were
being said
even though i'm here thinking this whole
time
you [ __ ] said you literally just said
i paid for your room paid for your
flight that's why you shouldn't complain
you justify being a total [ __ ] douche
bag to her
he needs to apologize you need to
apologize bro straight up
you justify being a total douche bag to
her because you bought her what is she a
peasant that you could just bring around
and [ __ ] on because you bought her
things
trisha should send him a check so he can
shut up yeah you want trisha to send you
a check
[ __ ] you bro what what's happening now
how'd you get here wait this isn't uh
live
no uh
the bullet being shot but they don't see
why the shot the shot was fired
okay oh no so what are you talking about
now
she creates a uh a a youtube video
and i tell the the girl that's doing my
hair i'm like yo let me borrow your
phone so i could watch hurt the video
on live so they
you guys got my first oh my god just
apologize bruh
yeah i just apologize the first reaction
out of me you get me okay so i see the
video on live
money this girl gets along with me
i'm thinking we get along so in the
video she's saying that
there's a car alarm going she didn't
like the service
because she felt i overcharged her okay
whatever she said it doesn't justify
what you said about
her she fell okay you over throughout
the night
um touch her up and
it seems like fair criticism brah not
[ __ ]
calling someone fat and her skin bad no
no no no here's the thing let me tell
you guys what i'm not going to apologize
when you're about oh
no no there's no need to apologize for
something that i knew i was saying
okay when someone is upset you don't say
no you need to apologize things to make
that person feel
you want to check [ __ ] you say [ __ ]
that's going to piss them off too
the same oh okay so
this guy's a doo-doo head what happens
and everybody knows i love that when he
gets challenged a little bit he starts
all of a sudden he's not that tough and
not that serious
interesting that we got to see that
happening live
to i got trisha's back on this one man
that was some rude [ __ ]
you know why does he keep showing me
this video
the story i guess well i'm clicking for
the accurate things
okay [ __ ] that who cares like suppose
she did say
that i charged her more yes or which is
some stuff like that
when you say that i'm talking about you
and i
really wasn't you're not even making
sure that's when it's going really
pissed me off you didn't even bring that
up in your videos
okay
yeah i didn't watch the video the latest
video recently
but they failed to show those parts
where i'm bringing out receipts
you didn't bring [ __ ] you [ __ ]
this guy's a douche case closed guys
closed
case closed i was ah man that's what
jeffrey that's what your brain does on
jeffree star
sounds like somebody wants this guy
obviously lives his life transactionally
right
i have no idea about him so i don't well
based on what he said about trisha
that she should just endure whatever uh
she should just endure whatever abuse
comes her way because
because he's buying her [ __ ] so that
that's how i assume his relationship is
with jeffrey you know what i mean he's
on that jeffrey t
so hard he's so desperate
he just debased himself
it's upsetting yeah
trish are you watching this yeah should
we have her call
him
man whatever trisha if you're out there
we got your back girl
you can message me on whatsapp let me
see if she messaged me
my mom messaged me oh my mom said
she's watching the show it says you look
like you have lost weight thank you mom
she said and my my parents are the
harshest critics they're telling me
straight up
my mom doesn't pull punches on the wait
[ __ ] should be like you're fat she's
like you look fat
tell you that way your mom wanted an
apology alive you should do it well
you're
whatever oh yeah i do owe my mom an
apology kind of made it sound really
douchy when he
was telling trisha about our proposal
he said that the ring his mom gave him
was trash i didn't mean that i
i so didn't mean it it was a grandma
yeah i so
i that was messed up i shouldn't have
said that so it was a family
it was a heirloom yeah i didn't i don't
know why i said that
i was just going over the story really
fast i didn't mean trash that's not what
i meant
i mean i said that but i wish i didn't
say it like that
anyway my mom said tell ela i had
fibroids removed also it's an easy one
day procedure
nothing to worry about oh there you go
nice nice let me see if trisha wants to
calm people seem into that idea
how do you know what people are into
here i'm looking at the chat you get
supervision you think so it's not that
far
maybe you can message your dan on the in
the frenemies chat
i don't know if she's watching or what
i'm on the opinion of like
you should save it for monday but maybe
not oh save it for bad day we do have a
show to do
well whatever messenger maybe we should
you know
look at awful
a good alfredo i mean if he wants to
then look at him
what are you doing he's so funny
you know if she wants to let's do it
because people are interested
yeah that was not cool that was
so disgusting what up oh my god i was
blown away by that guy
oh my god i gotta update
god his instagram just went private holy
[ __ ]
my soldiers don't [ __ ] around the
soldiers do not
[ __ ] around holy [ __ ]
he just went private he was out mounting
his old defense and everything
what did he say wow he went private huh
he can't take any
little clown emojis bro you talk so much
[ __ ] and you couldn't
exactly you couldn't be private he's my
phone number
listed in his uh instagram bio
well okay first of all it's in it's in
his public
thing so probably one of those fake
bullshits uh
i want to stay in touch with you guys
let's just be clear we do not condone
no no no no no no well it's in his
i'm just saying it's just it's just in
his in his profile so it's not like zach
was
showing anything not public but we're
not trying to harass him
no i just wanted to defend my girl dude
just apologize you don't have to private
your account and do all this hubbub just
[ __ ] apologize for being so rude to
her
and basically confirming i like her
i showed the receipts in the video and
it's like actually the only receipt you
showed is of your shitty personality
yeah we got the receipts on that
good point he's like yeah we were making
fun of your skin and calling you fat
but that's just only because you are
it's like oh [ __ ] dude you really got
her
you really proved their point
um another update the number is gone
oh [ __ ] you took it down
dude just apologize if you apologize
oh don't spam the number and chat you
guys right now
wait what who's doing that dan said
there are people spamming the number
we're not we're not arrested guys don't
do that you can block it you can do a
block and block the number in the chat
if you can you can ban the you know i
mean the digits
don't do that you guys please do not
call that number i'm not saying that
ironically do not
call the number
anyone who drops out i'm banning them if
they do
people who drop the phone number will be
banned with peace and love
with peace and love all people dropping
a number will be banned i'm warning you
peace and love wow the foot soldiers are
will not be stopped
that was so disgusting i'm still just
kind of like
gross close
i find it interesting we're trying to
get trish life is so wild i feel like
we're just getting a taste to like i
know the stuff she goes to well i
thought she was being dramatic and then
i oh as
you know like oh trisha's being dramatic
but i watched the clip and i was like oh
the thing is you know his homies talking
like that you know
him you know jeffree star is saying the
same exact [ __ ]
yeah he's just a little bit smarter he's
not going on live and advertising what a
psycho he is yeah
not cool i did message trisha so she
gets back to us
i will let you know
um oh sean balog just messaged me
he said jesse had the same i don't know
if you want me to read this text sean
but
he said that
it's an easy procedure that's all you
said
so it sounds sounds all good i didn't
even know that was a thing man
me neither apparently you get like spots
on your
uterus or something yeah or something
and then they just take it
right off yeah
female anatomy the more you know
also to check for it they had to put
like uh
fluid in there and do like a ultrasound
with fluid it's
weird i think this the name of this
episode you know you owe me forever
because everything that we have to do
it's all me yeah i know
and you're just home sleeping and i and
i got fluid
ultrasounds look it's happening yeah no
i am
totally appreciative of that i i i
i don't feel like i i feel like i tell
you tonight
bro how are you gonna act how are you
gonna act like i never ever see even say
no
like i am appreciative you know
i always say that
i mean straight up i'm just really happy
that you have to do it and not me
nice truthfully if it had to be me i'd
do it but it sucks
[Laughter]
i don't have a choice it's awesome
because i don't have a choice usually
it's like
like this morning it was 6 00 am and
theodore woke up and
we were like having we're having i
wouldn't say we weren't arguing but we
were debating who would go get him yeah
so anyway i went up and got him
but when it comes to like having a baby
there's no debate so it's easy
like man i'd do it if i could
i would totally do it if i could do it
some people are wondering if drunk ben
is
what is he doing today don't encourage
drunk ben that guy's gonna be broke
okay drunk ben 7 a good one though i
hope it wasn't too hungover oh i was
saying we should we should rename the um
the episode two squashing two beefs and
creating a new one
[Laughter]
two beefs back one beef forward is born
yeah
i want to say uh just real quick um
thank you to everybody who's joining
these members um it's been an incredible
amount of people doing it on today's
episode for whatever reason so
thank you thank you thank you to all of
our members
i will say three or four hundred people
have become members over the course of
the stream fantastic
thank you guys the membership helps the
show a lot it helps keep sustain
a good even plane you know we've had a
lot of uncertainty in the show
and we're trying our best to deliver
some good value
as well for the memberships as like like
i was saying earlier in the show
the episode that's going to be posting
tomorrow that we had the delay a day
for reasons i've already explained is up
already for members because we don't
have to censor anything on that we don't
have to worry about getting approval
from youtube
we put it up as soon as it's recorded
and the members get it immediately
yeah so that's actually been up since uh
wednesday evening
yeah wednesday evening so you get it
okay so we're
asking for the critical yeah
so thank you thank you to all of our
members we love and appreciate you
it's so important to the show without
you i would unfortunately have to fire
ian
thank you who is doing something i don't
know what ian what are you doing you're
you're inspecting something so closely
on your desk
talk to us i was just scanning through
comments
on my phone oh good thank you
[Laughter]
okay okay let's move on to
charlie critical reviews so critical
once again i was kind of
get into that before we got into the
sidetrack with this new drama yeah
but they talk about one of the old
dramas that we are burying
what does it mean squash the beef anyway
it's like can you squat that's like
taking beef and like squashing it
like a meat tenderizer you know oh okay
yeah is that squashing it's more like
pounding
it's what comes to mind when i hear that
term i have no idea squash the beef
because that seems like more dramatic
like
we're gonna squash you should eat the
beef let's look up origin
cook the beef um they're saying youtube
finally made it easier to join via
iphone
oh that's fantastic that's probably why
yay it's got so many people for a long
time
i think there was a dispute between
apple and
youtube app yeah apple wants their
thirty percent
and then i think that youtube's action
that goes through the uh
right so they were negotiating i think
with apple
and it sounds like they finally were
able to add the button that's fantastic
it's there thank you to everybody on
apple you now have a members button
let's
go origin of squash the beef i actually
want to know
i'm curious and i'm sure everybody else
is too
oh interesting wow it goes it goes way
back eh
here pork bear
pork barrel wait what is all this
[ __ ]
ham it up what is this dumbass turkey
yo hold on this is a dumb artist i was
getting
i was getting excited but this is
actually just horribly dumb
it's like meat related idioms like okay
and not even squash the beef by the way
ham it up ham it up cold turkey
how the sausage is made shut up miriam
webster don't you have
words to define it's horrible
thank you okay
um squash the beef what so some maybe
someone else should try to figure this
out
thank you anyway
so char so we sent charlie a package you
guys may recall
we sent him a wikifeet hat signed by me
number one on the website
and we also sent him the smells like my
butthole candle because i know he had
previously reviewed goops gwyneth
paltrow smells like my vagina candle
and i thought he had a good palette
uh so packaging so i sent him it may
look like i just got out of the shower
and my hair's still a bit damp but
that's only an illusion
a ruse from the master trickster charles
what this
actually is is grease i've got a thick
layer of gamer gunk on me right now i'm
real
filthy a real dirty boy it's been almost
three days since my last shower
and today i'm gonna be smelling ethan
klein's [ __ ]
it's gonna be hard to know what smells
worse his butthole or
me so it'll be a really nice clash of
aromas
now i'm sure all of you know by now that
i'm the preeminent expert when it comes
to genital candle fragrances i just have
a super sniffer that cannot be matched
by other human beings
i've shown you its power when it comes
to gwyneth paltrow's vagina i've always
wondered is he just riffing or is he
reading something because he's really
i don't think he's reading anything i
think he's just good he's quite good
yeah
just doing that yeah he's really
impressive he's super funny just
yeah he's got a good uh
the dude's got a good brain for talking
smart guy funny guy of course i always
have them nearby just in case of
emergency
we have good power notice how much our
candle looks like hers i have to
kind of tip my hat at how what a great
job we did on this candle in gwyneth
paltrow's vagina both of which i've
huffed extensively
i've made two videos about these bad
boys so i'm really like the scent
sorcerer when it comes to gwyneth
paltrow's vagina
i'm the the patriot of [ __ ] perfume
from gwyneth paltrow
and ethan from h3h3 really wanted to
test my nostrils to see
what i would think of his butthole smell
now of course this is my first rodeo
smelling butthole in fact far from it
nobody and nothing smells more [ __ ]
than i do the only thing that might even
come close is
dogs when they're meeting a new dog and
they start sniffing their anal glands
but other than that i'm at the top of
the food chain when it comes to
analyzing [ __ ] smells
so he came to the right place he even
sent me this nice hat that says to
charlie
always number two from ethan number one
and it's about wikifeed
because he [ __ ] tanked my wikifeed
rating because he was scared of my feet
on there
by the way everyone that tanked my wiki
rating you ruined my christmas
all right that was just that was
uncalled for but anyway
hey bro i'm just saying look i'm not
here to say if it was called for or not
i'm just saying you got to check your
facts before you got there and claim to
be number one
now the foot soldiers decided to
retaliate
okay i had nothing to do with that my
guns
i may have gone to your page and said
give him one star okay
but if they chose to do that of their
own volition i didn't force anybody but
holes let's go ahead and smell the
candle
i will say i love the packaging and if
you want my first impression even before
lifting it out
the box that this came in smelled
atrocious
when i first picked up the box i thought
he had just taken a pile of like tuna
dumped it in there and then covered that
with like dog [ __ ]
it was really strong and the hat smells
just like it too
that's awesome with ethan klein's
[ __ ] smell
it's like so pungent that it's ruined
all of the air molecules that it touches
it is actually [ __ ] terrible smelling
i don't know if it's the candle
or just whatever happened with the box
and [ __ ] again but it is
absolutely oh yeah
i will say the packaging is spectacular
even better than gwyneth so i gotta say
our packaging is better than gwyneth's
goops [ __ ] candle
like that's just pathetic man
one of my biggest regrets of the past 20
20 year was not making more of those
candles
[Music]
next year yeah we we even debated doing
a re-up but i think yeah
i think it's gonna be a holiday special
exactly i gotta say the people who
did get their hand were fortunate enough
to get their hands on that i was hoping
for i wanted so i want somebody to light
it in the company of others
and film their gradual understanding of
this like what is that smell
well it's interesting because as you'll
see
you haven't seen this full reaction i
did i watched it because he
he says lighting it actually dissipates
the bad smell
you know not my experience
yeah yeah not my experience but he
burned it for a long time
but so maybe we should do a new
formulation for
2021 holiday where it's like smells like
my
my uh balls is too pedestrian it's more
like
my huge my gooch yeah
your taint sounds smells like my taint
what'd you say zach
it smells like my bo no that's too
pedestrian
smells like my taint
because it's a very specific smell
you're going for it's not just beethoven
because it sounds funny smells like my
gucci are good
smells like my gooch those a lot of
people be like what is a gooch so that's
kind of funny too
no my food doesn't smell like that
well we kind of cornered ourselves you
start with [ __ ] there's nowhere
really yeah
you know it's not that it's a work it's
different it's not i'm not trying to
make it smell worse
trisha is making a bunch of tick tocks
and apparently she's my
mad at shane now and ending the
friendship with him what
sorry guys i gotta i have to get to the
treasure
friendship with shane is over oh well
maybe then we can finally
hold on hold on hold on
i got it well you guys uh i gotta i
gotta see it i can see i'm
i'm looking she posted about 12 tick
tock i'm sorry 13 tick tocks right now
okay i'm going to watch i'm going to
watch it smells like my toes
my toes my toes don't smell smells like
my feet
smells like my wiki feet number one on
the website all right let me finish this
avi you put together a reader's digest
of the anti-shane videos please
wish me luck good luck like this
it's really oh wow wow wow
so with gwyneth paltrow's candles as
i've made very clear in the past i've
been very vocal about it
her candles don't smell like [ __ ]
surprisingly
i haven't uh able to get in touch with
her agent to actually uh
schedule a play date where i can smell
her vagina and compare it to the candle
but i can't imagine her vagina smells
anything close to the candle
it just doesn't they smell like lazy
candles that are also kind of bad
like they can get really strong like not
good
smell but never like vaginal sweat smell
this smells terrible like this smells
like
liquid ass you know that like liquid ass
spray that you spray in your parents car
and they're like oh who just [ __ ] their
pants you know this is gross i know and
you're like
i kind of took that as a slight because
i was hoping that the fragrance was more
nuanced than that
and i think it was i think it is more
nuanced than like liquid ass
why because it it's it's it's
it's not meant to just smell like liquid
ass don't you understand it's
musk it's sweat we tried to create a
real nuanced fragrance
so it's just good ass sounds pretty
deadly to me so just write it off as
as liquid ass is frankly i think that
should be a compliment
i know he means it as a compliment
but me as the architect of this scent
uh you got pranked it's actually just
liquid ass but i did [ __ ] myself too
this is what that smells like it's
really
[ __ ] strong my compliments to the
chef
i'm sure he had hundreds of flavor
scientists working on really concocted
something evil
in this candle yeah my god
that is impressive it's like he just
like trimmed his ass hair
and like sprinkled it into the
funnily wax that was my original idea
which you guys vetoed
because you thought it was too gross
yeah was i wanted to put little
like fibers fibers in there that look
like pubes
yeah the the people that made this aroma
prime is the company and uh our
our fan actually liam who is a regular
watcher who reached out to us
um they're experts at this i mean they
they make the
the unique smells that you smell at
theme parks and stuff like this is
this is what they do no yeah we have
scientists yeah
literal scent scientists working on this
you guys really think that the pubes in
the wax was too gross
i mean maybe i personally did maybe
people maybe
listen it's not you know what i mean
yeah okay
maybe next time i haven't even burnt it
yet
holy [ __ ] i'm actually i'm actually
skeptical if there's even wax
this looks like the alginate that you
use for edible anus molds
i'm actually curious about like the
creation of this candle how it was made
like what did you do ethan like prolapse
your rectum and just like stamp each
candle with it
like it is that would probably smell
better than the candle
i certainly wasn't expecting that i
thought this was again going to be just
like a lazy candle
but this is rancid this is absolutely
repugnant even before burning the candle
this [ __ ] thing smells like if you
climbed into the back of a dump truck
and found a rotting corpse in there
that's still decomposing
it is absolutely awful a lot worse than
i was expecting so
good work on that thank you really
captures the
beautiful aroma of [ __ ] so that his
reaction
can't wait to have this burning
emanating throughout the room spreading
i'll let that burn for a little while
make a wish on it so i did notice that
when you say if you blow out the candle
ethan klein has a little g-spot
tingle interestingly enough whiting the
candle
has immediately made all of the all so i
did notice that when you light the
candle the smell
kind of retreats but i wouldn't say it
smells good
it kind of retreats i guess i couldn't
uh
leave it on for too long so kind of you
get used to it yeah after a while
i've been letting it ruminate here for
like like a minute
two minutes maybe it's it's really like
tamed everything it like
reeled back all the flavor
it's super odd like now that it's
burning
it just smells like another [ __ ]
candle
it's like all of the latent ass juice
was in like the dried wax and the second
you start melting it
it just reverts to normal wax
yeah it's like a de-evolution like when
you're trying to stop it i'm going to
write you
you like bring it back down yeah yeah he
ultimately says it it sounds
it's nothing but a pool of wax i will
say the wax coloration is very
interesting it's like urine in there
so maybe he also took like a piss in
there and froze it like an ice cube
which would be cool that'd be a nice
little
special surprise inside the cereal box
but as far as the smell goes
the whole awful ass smell that the
candle did have
is gone this actually smells like summer
when i was a child like
you know outside in the sun you know
dad's got the hose and he's spraying the
hose in the backyard
and then ethan klein has his pants down
somewhere in the background
and it smells a little bad over there
but otherwise it just
it smells like summer i don't know it it
really doesn't smell bad this is
actually a pretty decent candle
at the moment like this would be a
candle i'd have just leisurely because
it's like
a really light non-offensive smell it's
like
oh i smelled a little something oh okay
and then that's it it's it's not
interesting yeah
it was horrible before i started burning
it and now
now it's kind of it's kind of relaxing
what it might have been is maybe the
first layer of wax
is where all of the the grime
and stench was held prisoner so by
burning off that
first outer rim here of saturn's rings
i've really just gotten into like the
more normal candle part
like the entire like flavor headquarters
is in that first
small film on the top and now that
that's gone it's just like
kind of normal candle smell but uh yeah
you know overall it would it smelled
like pure [ __ ]
immediately but when you actually do
burn the candle
yeah it just doesn't smell bad it really
doesn't pretty impressive stuff thank
you even mine if this is what your
[ __ ] smells like
i mean congratulations to ela then i
mean that is that is something special
like if this is what your butthole
actually [ __ ] smells like with like
burnt
candle on it impressive stuff that's
like giving yourself a lysol
enema it's crazy that's got to be the
cleanest colon of all time if this is
what it smells like really
really good work well yeah anyway i'll
blow it out because sometimes that
brings out the latent
potential
i feel like when i blew it out the scent
he said became let it roll for like 10
minutes though um it could have
never lasted that long right exactly but
he does
make an interesting comment at the very
end here this is just [ __ ] crazy so
i've let it sit for another like three
or four minutes just to cool down and
just kind of stew in its own filth
smells [ __ ] horrible again when this
thing is lit
fine in fact even good sometimes when
it's just sitting
it actually does smell like ethan klein
wiped his ass and then just stuffed the
toilet paper in my hand
so this thing needs to just like burn
eternally like the olympic flame
because otherwise it's awful interesting
but when it's burning it's fine so he
said once he blew up the flame
then the smell was good or bad again
yeah i know
i know that fascinating stuff it's awful
again yeah
so thanks shout out to critical we have
buried the hatchet really good at
reviewing yeah yeah he totally we got to
get him an infomercial or
on this out products uh so update
um i actually have trisha on the line oh
what
she's calling wait i thought you said
she didn't want to call it yeah you said
that originally but uh
oh we got trish on the line she's here
yeah so um
the tricia faded the tricia princess
trick unless it's another princess trish
in the waiting room bring her in
what are we waiting for i'm bringing her
in now standby did you watch the shane
stuff
maybe do you have a yeah it was just one
video okay
can you hear me or not yeah we can hear
you did you see us going after that
[ __ ] douchebag yeah i didn't want to
watch the live because the d'angelo
thing but then i saw the part where you
guys were being nice and i was like okay
let me go on here real quick
oh my god this is a guy such a [ __ ]
oh well like he was here at my house
yesterday my security guard i showed the
text messages on my tick tock my
security guard i showed him the video
because at the end of the video the
guy's like i'm gonna [ __ ] you up you're
going to be anorexic by the time i'm
done with you the only person your
funeral is going to be your mom
he said that yeah on the video on his
instagram live the previous one
and so i made a video because i was like
oh my god what do i do so i sent
the video to my security guard and he's
like oh that guy was here today he's
taking pictures of your car he's with
another guy in a black dodger they
circled around they circled around
um yeah and so i called
the security company today i got another
security guard over here and then our
our centers were going off at night last
night like front driveway front driveway
and the one security guard we had kept
sleeping so we got like two now at night
and it was like this whole thing i said
i didn't know he said such awful things
i watched his
full live it was like 35 minutes and
it's him just telling me that i'm like
this fat piece of [ __ ] that
he's gonna he's gonna i'm gonna get
what's coming to me like that i like
he's
like by the time i'm done like the time
he's gonna [ __ ] me up that i'm gonna
look like i'm gonna
you know in anorexic i'm gonna be in a
funeral like all this crazy [ __ ] and
he's like crazy this guy does my wigs
for a long time
and he like would tell me he would show
me like fights he goes in i'm like
beating people like beating people to
death he'd always like yeah i killed
that [ __ ] like all that [ __ ]
like he's crazy and it like scares me
so that's why i went on tick-tock
because i was like i don't know what to
do like i don't like
like the cops can't do anything unless
he shows up and my neighbor's a cop
which is good but like until he like
comes back but he really can't do
anything other than he had the threat so
they can like they can
they can i guess arrest him i guess if
there's already threats against me well
he wasn't that tough people sent him a
few clown emojis and he made his whole
instagram
private i i haven't even seen all that i
was like i just i was like catching my
breath i don't know but he is he's like
scary like he's like
like he's he's like well i can tell he
has anger problems because he like
snapped on you so fast and by the way
when he was like when he was trying to
justify his behavior
all he said was that you said that he
overcharged you
right right i i had said that in a
recent video that that he did and he
overcharged me whatever
he never said his name nothing four
thousand dollars and it normally was
three thousand dollars
four thousand dollars for what which i
paid for by the way for a week two weeks
what that's how much it cost
it doesn't usually cost that much i
don't know that seems like a lot oh my
god
they gave you context like it was on a
trip that went on with jeffree star last
valentine's day and they were
they basically told me they basically
made fun of me while i was on the trip
basically
yeah like he said it and and jeffrey too
and i was trying to be cool with jeffrey
because shane and rylan stuck up for
jeffrey and i just was like all right
i'm going to be cool i'm not going to be
that mean or whatever i'm not going to
come for jeffrey and expose him but
i finally just kind of like let it down
a little bit i'm like he's not a nice
person whatever
and then i said the thing about jay
overcharging me and like he did he said
thank me for my skin they said that i
was boring that they wanted me to go
yeah
i offered to pay i offered to pay for
the i offered to pay towards the private
jet i offered to pay my hotel room i
offered to pay
every single thing like they never took
me to dinner he's like oh jeffrey paid
for all your meals never
they'd always ditched me before dinner
like who cares what he paid for
huh who cares what he paid for his whole
thing was like oh we paid for all this
[ __ ]
so you have to endure and whatever we
say and do to you it's like what
it was the worst trip of my life and i
came home and i told shane and i told my
sister i told my mom everyone who knew i
came home i came home early they were
awful they basically like smacked food
out of my hand told me i shouldn't be
eating told me i was poor because i
asked the price of a balenciaga bag like
oh my god you have to ask the price of
how much that is before you buy it like
you're so poor
by the way that guy's a hairdresser like
what the [ __ ] is he to talk about asking
prices
oh my god no i know it was and he said
that too he's like
she runs at how she lives in she doesn't
own it and that's something jeffrey says
like that's that's their petty [ __ ] that
they say and i was like
it's just so crazy to me it's so insane
and like i'm just so sick of people like
getting away with that stuff especially
jeffrey like rylan just had jeffrey on
his podcast and it pissed me the [ __ ]
off because jeffrey is
the worst person and these are the and
it shows by that guy's video
like i am a crazy person i like i have
drama with people but i never like go
for people's like
look smells i'm gonna say they're dead
like all this stuff especially jeffrey
and that guy
there's so many low blows i could take
it i don't because it's like
what is the [ __ ] is wrong with people so
wait i have never heard of people
acting like that and it was all low blow
even never
yeah it was all evil so wait what's
wrong okay
av said you made a video about shane a
tick talk about shane
no someone just said like um what why
like
i don't even know what the tic tac was
something along the lines of like why
does shane still support him or
something i'll tell you right now it
says
is your best friend shane gonna stick up
for you and then this is and it just it
just kind of did trigger me because
they had him on chain on ryland's
podcast like just a week ago talking
about the kanye west thing and i'm like
this person's
shitty like he's a shitty person to me
and anyone who's been shitty to them
i just disregard you know what i mean
but he's an actual awful person they
knew the week it happened how awful it
was and i was just i was just
i'm just done i'm just done i was
protecting jeffrey because he was
friends with shane but i'm just so
done with it all and that's why i was
just like i don't know it just was like
a lot and i'm just i'm just really
heated at the moment
because all this is happening and the
people showed up to my house not once
but twice and like threatening me and
all this crazy [ __ ] and it's just like a
lot it's just like a lot
because why because i said like i like
and he was he like harassed me
before the trip i asked him how much of
the weight how much of the weight he's
like jeffrey's got you jeffrey's got you
don't worry about it
and then like the day i come home early
and don't come home with them he's like
oh you owe me four thousand dollars for
the wigs and i'm like that's fine it was
a sunday i'm like i have to transfer
money and all this crazy [ __ ] and then
i paid him it wasn't an issue i paid him
i didn't even say that you overcharged
me i just paid him and then
i was like i just left a bad taste in my
mouth i talked about it briefly and it's
in a mukbang or whatever i didn't even
see his name i was just like
this is this is what happened and they
were awful they're the worst people and
that video proved it and i was like this
is the case it actually does prove it
it's interesting because it would it was
just like your word
and but like in that video he literally
admits
to him and shane calling you fat making
fun of your skin
saying you were born what did i say
jeffrey oh jeff what did i say
oh sorry i mean jeffrey and his little
homie
making fun of your skin calling you fat
he was saying you were boring it's like
what kind of [ __ ] comment is that
you're not there to end it because i
didn't want to go out to the club with
them but when they were out of the club
there's a guy that was with us on the
trip that wasn't on jeffrey's payroll
that made a video but took it down
and he said he had video footage of them
at a club that i didn't go to and the
whole night that they're supposed to be
at like partying having fun they're just
talking about how disgusting i am
and how greasy my skin is and how my
hair is from i 100 believe that
after watching that video there's a
video there's a
guy took it down but i'm sure someone
re-uploaded it the guy that was with us
on the trip i forget his name but he was
just a friend
and he's like they just kept saying how
poor trisha was and disgusting
or crazy how poor what kind of [ __ ]
that's not a criticism
it's just it just just so yeah
i don't like jeffrey the chat is all
saying
how beautiful you are trisha people are
saying the chat is writing
it and i've just been having so many
issues and on the first video he's just
mocking like
that i'm suicidal and stuff like that
it's just like all this crazy [ __ ] and
it's like watching it all over again i'm
like these people
will suck and like i'm so tired i'm
trying to like tiptoe around it and even
on the last friend of me and i was like
maybe i'm too hard on jeffrey but no
this is like him and
this is jeffrey's like bffv this is how
they talk about people like this is how
they talk about this
why are they still friends with jeffrey
i have no idea
but i don't want to say i'm not that
person to be yeah but shane and jeffrey
are like they have like this whole
history together of selling the makeup
and making a bajillion dollars
yeah maybe that's why and that's the
only thing i can think of because he's
just a shitty shitty person
and i'm never to be like don't be
friends with this person or whatever but
it's just like shitty thing after
anything not once did jeffrey ever
defend shane during any of this like
they both just hid you know what i meant
and i was just like and i stuck up for
and i was like jeffy's a shitty friend
and a shitty person
and i'm probably gonna get killed like i
honestly i'm actually like scared
because like the person's like come to
my house like my security guard why are
they coming to your house i don't
understand that
i don't know the guy told me he was in a
black dodge charger then he got out with
his friend there was two of them
took pictures of the car the guy my
security guard got out of his car
because they stay in a car which car
your
pink your pink uh rolls
no it's in the garage what were they
taking pictures of oh
oh like of it was moses's car and my
other car
i have a different car and not the rolls
royce the bentley yeah
is it possible people are just looking
at the nice cars
no it always is and that's 100 true but
i sent him the video of the guy he's
like oh that 100 was this guy that was
here twice yesterday
and it was like not a doubt in his mind
he's like that's the guy
weird because they got out of their car
people take pictures of the car all the
time and like that's fine whatever but
he's
he had specifically remembered them and
um
yeah so that was that was it and now i
have another security guy coming over
today so
there's two so one goes to the bathroom
the other one's here that's crazy
wow yeah but anyways i saw that i didn't
want to be a part of this because i
thought d'angelo was on but then i was
like oh then you guys are sticking up
for me and being like amazing so then i
was like we didn't really travel man
yeah we had a good combo with d'angelo
yeah i didn't watch it but i'm sure he's
fine i'm sure he's nice and
whatever it's fine i get why people
don't like shane i'm not like trying to
defend him i just like love shane so
like no matter what if you kill somebody
i'll be like oh i love shane you don't
mean
fair enough yeah okay
well well that was painful to watch i
really couldn't believe this guy
i think that proves beyond a shadow of a
doubt that everything you say about
jeffrey is true
he literally admitted it's interesting
right
right and that's what and to be honest
like it was that's why i was like oh
finally people like see this [ __ ]
i mean like it's it's so it's so and
it's it's honestly it's worse yeah
it's funny or jeffrey's probably gonna
be pissed cuz this guy basically just
outed him
as all that [ __ ] being chill
you know i know and that's his friend
that's his person that he had with him
on his trip to wyoming two days ago so
this is someone that's like close to him
saying this and
yeah he had him without even trying but
honestly like
aren't they making fun of you for being
poor isn't that like jeff bezos hanging
out with jeffree star and being like
he's so
poor he can't afford his own yacht like
you're not poor
yeah you're wealthy um yeah i mean i
i i don't know it bothered me for some
reason i don't know why
he's so poor she's so poor she doesn't
even own her own
15 million dollar mansion psychos
it's so it's so weird it's so odd i was
so confused i don't know
the whole thing i just wanted to put it
out there because like it was actually
kind of scary when i saw like the
the first ig live was like 38 minutes
long and there was like so much hatred
towards me and i was like holy [ __ ] this
is actually like kind of scary
yeah yeah and then when i sent the
screenshot yeah you're so excited
my car not thinking anything but yeah
he's like he's here but he was so angry
and i've never
never had someone like just that much
hatred just you know like when it's
something like low blows like that i was
like oh this is weird
yeah he felt aggressive to me just in
the way he was talking
yeah he is aggressive i mean like he'd
show me videos all the time of him like
kicking people's asses which is like
that's what scares me is because i know
his history like he he
there's a viral video someone he's no
he's like i don't know
he's he's pretty big but he was at six
flags there's a viral video and he's
jumping into the fight of beating like
these people up at six flags and he's
like that's me that's me
rapping at six flags that's like the
trashiest thing i ever heard in my life
dude
it's a viral video it's like a family
fighting a family and he just jumps in
and he like will show everybody
dude dude if you're watching you are the
trashiest human being alive
getting in a fight at six flags is rock
bottom dude
yeah but i thank you guys for always
like defending me at first i was like oh
no because like
i clicked on the live and i heard you
guys talking about shane and i was like
let me click out and then i was just
like whatever i don't care like at least
you guys are like defending me and i was
just like oh [ __ ] so
and i just i just it just makes me
nervous and i feel like the more i just
get it out there at least people will
know because like
i know i'm like paranoid a lot and i
hope i'm like just paranoid about this
but like if i
get killed when i go outside or
something without moses like like at
least people will probably know like
there's a direction you know it's not
just
no one well as you always say if you do
get murdered that is pretty iconic
well i hope it's not by here by jay
that's pretty good that would it would
be less iconic
if you could choose to be murdered by
any person who would it be
i guess jeffrey himself that'll probably
get down bigger yeah
interesting that's more iconic yeah i
wonder what you'd have to do to get him
to murder you
i don't want this i don't this is going
to be like a last clip of trisha or
something i don't even want this out
there because i feel like it's going to
be like bad
so but but i'm just saying of everyone
on the earth jeffrey would be the best
person to kill you
in terms of iconic points yeah because i
feel like jim carrey could play him or
something in the movie
yeah jeffrey if you're watching
we love don't send your people to do it
just do it yourself do it yourself
yeah yourself i'm pretty sure you could
overpower jeffrey though
uh i don't know
well like yeah
so um well we'll see you on
monday yeah live
yeah we're doing trivia on monday but
i'm glad to see you're not crying
because i ever i think everyone in the
chat was feeling like
they wanted to see that you're okay
because it it honestly looked so bad to
be on the receiving end of that
video no it wasn't well i didn't i did a
youtube video earlier i was like shaken
up but i feel like now that more people
know about it and that i have people
here moses is on his way back like i
feel a little like
better but i was definitely like shaken
up because i just felt like holy [ __ ]
like this is it you know
yeah so aggressive so angry i was like
what the hell
yeah but anyway um he showed his true
colors though
we will see you on monday we're gonna be
in trivia we'll be eating grilled cheese
and apparently you
you you posted on instagram some cookies
which
apparently i understand you want as well
so
if you ever want any specific food on
frenemies just post it on instagram
because i'm so poor i can't afford them
so yeah
yeah we can afford them we can afford
the cookies that's why i got it yeah
all right all right see you on monday
bye
hi trish we stan a queen
oh my god that was my favorite part of
the last
frenemies um trisha's subliminal message
to you
oh yeah that was so funny
how was i supposed to understand that
she led with peanut butter
like if she wanted me to understand that
she wanted to eat grilled cheese
why beat it with peanut butter she says
people eat grilled cheese with peanut
butter
nobody does that right i didn't think so
either but
i've since heard that i guess that is a
thing in some places
how you put it in the sandwich i'm not
really i don't really know
i don't want to look up a recipe this
week because we're making them on monday
so
hold on hold on let me tell you peanut
butter
i don't see how it goes grilled cheese
let's see it's a wonderful thing
you know about this oh yeah freak you do
yeah well i mean we're talking about a
grilled charlie from italy sunny in
philadelphia oh right
and it's it's actually pretty good it
works
wouldn't you just rather grilled cheese
yeah it isn't
peanut flavored wouldn't you just rather
like the grilled cheese
why i mean if you want to take a walk on
the wild side
i don't people saying grilled pbj is so
good i mean
i could see that now i'm just looking at
peanut butter and jelly
that's what i'm saying like a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich what do you
mean grilled peanut butter it's just
yeah it's a peanut butter jelly sandwich
it doesn't matter if you toast the bread
or not
right i don't like better with the
cheese seems
odd i don't like it at all well you're
gonna eat it on monday
frank sinatra's favorite cheeseburger
had peanut butter on it
yeah well he's dead so do the math
[Laughter]
okay ela i haven't had a hamburger in
like years no
no i
walk my ass off every week
eating fatty ah trisha
but i only eat one meal a day everybody
says i look good
let's keep it going i'm doing it for you
right but i eat one meal a day and i
walk for like two hours but you don't
want that one meal to be a burger
no it doesn't matter because even if i
go
even if i go all out it's like what max
1200 calories
i guess but you might be hungry again
fatty tricia stop this doesn't it this
doesn't concern you
i just defended you and now you're
calling me fat
um how long we've been going dan uh
quite a while
um kind of so much almost two and a half
hours
uh we should wrap it up
but there's so much here there's just so
much here i'll think that you should eat
the burger
that's exactly people think food
soldiers you've got you've done it again
here's the thing you the thing about the
diet is to be sustainable you have to
treat yourself
but how frequently you had pizza like
the other day
no it was like a week ago you know it
was not it was like my cheat meal
for no reason i swear to god it was a
week ago eel is tripping
it was maybe it was over the weekend i
think
so that's not quite a week ago but but
it wasn't just the other day
i need to start writing it down for your
benefit sure
i think people would be interested in a
food diary
okay i would be by the way i didn't
really enjoy the pizza it was kind of
haha [ __ ] i'm laughing because you big
mad
you said you didn't enjoy the pizza no
it was like it doesn't count then
right it was it was disappointing
because of my business no i'm not i'm
just saying
that i didn't enjoy it was a shame
because it was from this italian place
and it was like
they called it what did they call it
flat bread
and it was just like super it was it was
a disaster
that's poser pizza they shouldn't be
they shouldn't legally be allowed to
call that pizza
well they did call it flatbread like
when you have a newborn baby you do a
baby journal
i'll do a food journal keep a food
journal i welcome you
but the thing is even if i'm eating
questionable
food i'm still under calorie and
exercising every day my trajectory is
still down okay
you got to trust me now pizza is
actually very nutritious
a.b i notice that you eat almost only
fast food
that's pretty crazy what's your eating
habit like
it's horrible it's it's because of well
moving for one
and then covid and my sleep schedule
combined they're kind of uh but you
don't have groceries in your house
i do but you don't cook you sand right
what is it you don't cook right oh i
just i don't poop
yeah uh cook yeah no i don't really cook
that much
um lena's been cooking this past week
though so
shout out to lena that's good if i'm
gonna
first time i went over to your house ab
you're like do you want something to eat
i'm like oh okay what do you guys
thought well i got an orange and orange
he made that whole story out of me
eating uh an orange and asking if he
wants one
he's like you want an orange oh did you
make that up zach
no that's all he has he's accusing you
of making that story up
i said he got the whole narrative from
me offering him just an orange
well that's all i got in your fridge did
you see my fridge i don't think you saw
my fridge
okay you weren't what was in your fridge
did you have more than an orange
i had some water bottles
somewhat some water bottles yeah so zack
is right
yeah no i had a few yeah i guess not a
lot
i'm just always like on the go like i'm
very impatient that's my problem with
everything so
like if i'm hungry i'm not going to make
something and lean is asleep i don't
want to wake her up so
i have to try i was for years man i
finally had you slow it down
if you prepare something at home you'll
eat faster than if you go to
probably a drink how old are you baby
28.
in two years you will stop being able to
uh
to eat that way oh i'm starting to feel
it i'm definitely trying to kill it
so what's your favorite fast food
um that's tough i don't know probably
this this is gonna
sound trashy maybe but kfc but i don't i
don't eat that that's the one i eat the
least often less
than any other yeah what do you eat most
often because if you're eating a lot of
fast food like what's your go-to
oh mcdonald's what do you got it's it's
just the closest one
probably a quarter pounder with cheese
meal not halal bro
if i can say one more thing just to give
you a little more love his sleep
schedule
he's like going to bed when i'm waking
up no
his sleep schedule is mine is messed up
his is truly [ __ ]
yeah i don't understand his sleep
schedule because like i'll send a
message at 3am
he'll answer oh and then i'll send you a
message at 6am
it's just it's just you always always
answer
well sometimes you don't actually sleep
i i'm a very light sleeper like if my
phone's on loud i'll hear it you think
you actually have a sleeping disorder or
you just have a bad schedule
no i think i have a sleeping disorder my
parents like
they like they don't sleep well either
but i'm definitely worse than they are
you have it diagnosed
uh no my my parents have got sleep uh
studies but i haven't
i need to get one ian did a sleep study
ian could recommend
you yeah yeah i got a plug
i know a guy last night i was actually
about to sleep early
but lena's like lena has like night
terrors and she talks a lot in her sleep
oh you know her like chanting yesterday
and she scared that she scared the [ __ ]
out of me like what's wrong with you
did you say now she does this thing
where she like could wake up and
conversate with me
while she's sleeping oh my god she's
like i have to send the samples or
something i think she's talking about
words
oh those are the worst nightmares i used
to have this all the time when i was a
uh
james charles is trending y'all oh yeah
i don't know why rug for clapping
back at a yeah this episode is off the
chain what's james charles stranding for
clapping back at a i'm assuming woman of
color
is woc well you
okay let's get the details before i call
that sister sister
snap sister snatched
sister snatched james charles is
trending
everybody sister snatched let's see
guys queen vaughn and james charles i
don't know who that is
what a stupid tweet one so this was from
today one from dude james charles is
such a diva like he gets in [ __ ] with
everybody okay one foundation cost fifty
dollars
artists have to buy every shade for
their kit and that's just the first step
it's expensive to work as a make up
artist either pay an artist rate
for the time school do it yourself or
get it done at a counter and risk
looking busted i didn't see the tweet
he's responding to him here
oh here it's on his twitter still you
can actually go to the tweet
uh oh is responding to a tweet that says
if you charge over 150 to do a face
of makeup you can go to hell
respectfully
and then he just like attacked her it's
like bro
just chill why you gotta it's like okay
maybe she's not
maybe maybe there's exceptions you know
but why you gotta like [ __ ]
attack her yeah she goes yo
and then he goes what a stupid tweet
you're gonna look busted he got really
sad
why did he have to go out of his way too
that's what he always does he just he
thinks he's such a [ __ ]
big deal
wasn't and then she responded to him
right hang on
now i'm in the [ __ ] drama sphere
right now but
james charles go to her page let's get
glam
let's get glam okay so she responded
what a dumb ass to be in my business
replying to something that has
absolutely nothing to do with you
i agree i'm having a debate about hood
prices baby
stay over there in hollywood where they
have you looking ghost
i mean she's right like mind your own
[ __ ] business why are you going on
blast
oh is she talking about this
bro you get you gotta shut up james
you're always causing [ __ ]
this is a little spooked mcgoot spook of
magoot
sounds racist
all right well okay we're up to date on
james charles drama
sister someone in the chat said ethan
asking evie about his diet is dirty
talk for him
oh dirty talk yeah but so
do you not eat a lot like what's your
deal do you not no i do eat a lot
how many meals how many meals every time
i hit you up you're like hold on i'm
driving back from del taco
or whatever yeah i'm usually want to get
a burger
you know i i mean i i did i got lucky i
guess with my metabolism but now it's
slowing down because it's going all to
my gut
and nowhere else my arms legs are still
skinny but getting a gut oh you're still
a stud
you are still stuck though wait how many
times a day do you eat
all over the place i feel like i'm
always snacking but like an actual like
meal probably three times so you you'll
eat like mcdonald's three times in a day
all right sometimes i mean that's all
it's gonna be crazy dude no
yeah you're gonna have to do it even at
my worst i don't think i would
you can't like when you hear your
thirties it's not gonna
stay like that your body will not stay
like that yeah yeah
yeah don't you even feel like you need
vitamins and [ __ ]
no interesting i always wonder about
that because people go
you gotta eat good food you gotta get
vitamins and you it's like
people survived on bread and rice like
like you know what i mean i think it's
different is vitamins overblown a little
bit
uh people literally survived on rice
that
has like nothing in it surviving yeah
but you know
look at ap he's flourishing the dude
eats mcdonald's for three meals a day
i wasn't bad when i was you can do that
in your 20s when you're young
he's 28. he's not that young well he's
just said he's starting to feel it
and yeah that is right around the time
where you start to feel it for sure
yeah i mean i ate like that in my 20s
too
you did oh yeah big time horribly ah
those were the days
well in college yeah every meal because
i didn't cook [ __ ] so it was like subway
mexican yeah that would be fast food
almost every day
you can't do that no you can't do that
sister snapped my pillow's trending
what's that about
yeah somebody in response to you saying
people lived off of rice
says and they died in their 30s life
expectancy was a lot shorter
when do you think it was the rice or
just like the the fact that they didn't
have ruining water
if somebody was literally only eating
rice that that isn't good
i guarantee you that's a fair that's i
mean that's a fair point sure
i know genetics has a big you know deal
a big part in it but i also feel like
i don't know i could be wrong my own
theory too it's like how you were raised
to like your diet growing up
um that can of course combined with your
genetics i feel like
contributes as well what is the my
pillow drama i love this my pillow guy
he's such a [ __ ] stooge
and by the way for the record i have
bought a my pillow it [ __ ] sucks
that's what zach said too it's a shitty
where you're like yeah i should yeah i
should have a better pillow
i don't think anybody likes my pillow i
think it's just everybody trying it
and then being like this pillow [ __ ]
sucks every time he comes on the tv
people are just wondering why he's in
the
um white house and he was seen
with a document that has notes on it and
like it's about the
but insurrection my fellow guy is
leading the insurrection
he's uh he's the napoleon of naga
there's like something marked off with a
marker
yeah oh wow they actually got a close-up
of it i love it
yeah he's the my pillow guy and trump
are like close which is so
odd like how much is that guys
what is his name mike liddell or some
[ __ ] yeah
um
his commercials are all about jesus too
like it's always like a close-up on his
cross
and [ __ ] you're like oh that's good what
what net worth of mike liddell from my
pillow 300 million
i actually would have thought more he
sells
pillows than infomercials i know but
he's got it's an empire man
why it's that what how do you make that
much money selling pillows
brah i don't know ashton ashton
asked ethan tell us more about your
workout routine i'm trying to drop some
20 20 weight and curious what you do
i'm still i'll get to that but this my
pillow guy he started his business in
2014
in a mere 16 years that is amazing
qvc picked it up too and that's where he
gets like the majority of but i don't
get it because the pillow [ __ ] sucks
like
does anyone like this pillow is that the
one that you just bought no that was a
different that one also sucks don't buy
pillows online
or don't bike pillows you see in
commercials just don't
i my thing with pillows i've tried good
bad
expensive cheap there's no trick with
pillows they
all suck just get one that you know what
i mean like there's no trick
it's just a [ __ ] pillow just get one
you like
there's no life hack but you would think
if you made this much money selling
pillows you would be onto something but
they really suck what kind of sleeper
are you
side me too
sick bro so my
my my workout routine is really simple i
just get on the trip so i have a peloton
which is basically just a stationary
bike and a treadmill
and i'll just walk on the treadmill at
about two miles per hour with a slight
incline and i just walk basically until
my feet are just
killing me which is usually like an hour
and upwards of two hours
and you can you burn like 300 calories
easily in an hour which is pretty
substantial
sometimes if my feet are hurting really
bad i'll just hop on the
um pellet the stationary bike
because it doesn't it doesn't hurt my
feet at all sometimes i'll start on the
stationary
bike do like 30 minutes and then finish
on the treadmill
so it's i like having both because
sometimes my feet just hurt
and so i can get on this the stationary
bike
but what's really what really helps for
me
is that i have something i like doing
that distracts me so i look forward to
doing it right and the time passes so
fast and
it's just such a breeze like i'm playing
even on the stationary bike i've got my
controller
i'm playing and the time just goes by so
fast and you're doing something you
enjoy
so it's just it's just a good time
honestly
i like it someone is saying um
put the incline up more and you'll burn
more calories
faster and jumping rope burns more
calories
okay here by jay's back y'all
send me the link baby let's see is he
going to go live
how come he just went private for like
two seconds it's weird
here by j you owe trisha apology
anyway i'm over here by jay
so that's about it oh i got the link i'm
back in
let's see oh yeah so have you seen the
cube pillow
it's for side sleepers i want to know if
it's good that's this
[ __ ] socks it's so dumb it's just
dumb it doesn't make sense it's so
stupid i don't think anybody that
actually
buys it likes it
that's it
i don't know but it's it look they have
the slick commercial and it looks like
oh that makes sense
you know but it does it doesn't it just
doesn't work there's no shortcut
higher incline speed for 30 minutes
okay guys people here are getting very
detailed
thank you so anyway that that about
wraps it up for today so remember guys
if
there's a new episode tomorrow
new episode of the hp podcast tomorrow
with with some redactions unfortunately
the few redactions yeah we had to chop
out which are available to our members
yeah
if you wanna if you if you're a member
and uh since we have a lot of new
members people might not be aware
if you um i believe you'll find them in
the community tab
there's a members tab now too it might
be there yeah if you go to the
communities tab
um there'll be posts there with links to
the members only version
and that you can get the the uncensored
episode
and it's available now for members and
otherwise they'll be out tomorrow
for everybody else and just real quick
we got a few donations about um
background play i know we have a lot of
new members we've acknowledged it before
but that's not on our end
they didn't fix that still i don't know
i still see the complaints about it
it's a it's it's a youtube thing i've
been bitching at youtube forever and i
don't know why
there's something i wonder if it's to
prevent people the only thing i can
think of is it
if it's to prevent people from
downloading it somehow
but to you know get around them they
told me it's a bug
so it's just a bug okay yeah well yeah
unfortunately it is
out of our control we're not we're not
intentionally turning it off
if that's what you thought but thank you
so much to all the members it really
makes a huge difference it's
very beautiful very nice god blessed uh
also just a little announcement at the
end of the show here teddy fresh next
week
is going to be care bears week so we
actually just got word today
oh wait we have to wait we have to oh no
we have to delay the
release this has been up on our website
for like a whole week
i know we've just been wayward today
i've just been sitting at home watching
the countdown i know but
people oh that's so sucky and that's why
it's just cove it is just the splash
screen you guys put together here though
we've had so much fun working on this
one and it took a long time to perfect
everything but
i cannot wait i didn't remember realize
you're wearing that
yeah it's a little carob is inside the
letters it's really cool
tell us about it yeah
that was fun it was a good episode thank
you guys for joining had fun as always
love being here with you guys love the
live show eh
hey i do love the love [ __ ] the
love the love i'm so glad we're doing
live again
we mentioned it earlier but we'll have
to figure out um
what to do about it next week right
because of uh ela will be out so you
guys want a live stream of my polyps
being removed why don't we just do it on
thursday
or something don't ask that people will
be like yes why don't we do
we can do it on saturday or thursday
uh yeah i guess well let's talk about it
because
yeah let's talk about some other
episodes planned for next week as well
so we'd have to
also just skip for a week as sad as that
is
tragic that would be true tragical
tragic
all right y'all you know how i feel
about you
and i'll give you a hint you're
listening to the hp i like you a lot
more than jada's hair likes trisha
i feel about you guys how jay if you
would convert what jay does here about
trisha into
the invert into love and appreciation
affection that's how i feel about you
guys
i joined to tellington not to be
disrespectful about mormonism
with peace and love peace and love i'm
sorry listen
i think mormons are the nicest people in
the world
i mean don't be mad at me about the
secret handshake some stooge [ __ ] put
a camera in his robe
it's crazy it's crazy that someone
penetrated that feet
and was just a total stooge like a total
undercover
it's pretty impressive probably someone
who was already
thinking of becoming an expert you think
so maybe you're right you know
you're watching it because that's a real
circle of troubles
wouldn't it be funny though if they were
just like the secret handshake come here
though it was just like
like but come on don't you know how to
do it like like what's up doc
what's up that's it
you're like what's up oh my god that's
kind of
that would be dumb i've seen some
messages saying be careful it goes
deeper than what you think
like people bringing up like illuminati
i know mormon goes deep deep deep deep
and i ain't [ __ ]
i don't want any part of it you know
about the whole thing
uh that mormons are
way over representative in the
intelligence
i think that it's because they um they
live such a clean lifestyle they're
considered
they're like perfect fbi agents right
and fbi too
maybe it's fbi and not cia actually or
maybe it's both i just know that there's
a lot of mormon
intelligence well i will say about
mormons i know mitt romney is like a
famous mormon he is
in my opinion conducted himself with so
much
respect and uh integrity throughout this
whole thing so
yeah i think he represents mormons well
gone through the end song so there's
starting the third rotation there's a
division
here people are saying don't eat the
burger and people are saying eat the
best well let's do a straw fall and
they're all
typing in all caps do the straw poll for
eat the burger
eat the poopo eat the burger
all i know is i'm starving because i
haven't eaten today
that's what i'm saying like it's three
o'clock and i haven't eaten anything
that's how we do it and then i have a
meal and i walk for a trillion years
i'll be hungry again later
no i cut it out i i go no more food
[ __ ]
this is sick here open the results
are actually here send me send me two in
the chat so i can put it on screen
someone said that in the chat all right
let's see
come on soldiers yes so close
well okay hold on the way that you
the way that you phrased it down is a
little [ __ ] up
no it's a noun i'm just saying it the
way he phrased it is [ __ ] up how close
it is
because he's well well there's a clear
winner here
yes is winning by you know 10
votes there's a lot points people than
that watching right now so i
i found that the margin never changes on
these things
you know that's interesting like you got
a sample
look the votes go up but then it's
always like that in straw polls they lit
like the sample size is so
statistically predictive
it doesn't ever change it's pretty
amazing all right
oh jeffrey tweeted about trisha drama go
click
send it hold on we can't help it
i'm sorry oh here he goes i have
personally apologized to trisha several
times last year about vegas and she
has never responded which is her right i
respect it and what happened is between
us don't drag me into new drama
not interested what someone else says
does not represent me
hmm well like you said he's probably
pissed at that guy yeah
yes no it does seem like to jeffrey's
credit it does seem i don't know what's
going on behind the scenes but it seems
like he wants no part
in this anymore you know what i mean
like he's trying to
stay out of it let me think about this
i mean that guy was way out of line for
sure yeah
and he he 100 yo
if you don't want to be dragged into
drama you better tell your homie to keep
his [ __ ] mouth closed then
because he brought you into it right
i mean you pop but
like so he's confirming what she says
which does mean that you're kind of a
like major [ __ ] psychopath
second tweet uh oh let's keep it going
jeffrey
someone said imagine if we didn't have
social media no one
would know what others did or thought
exactly
i've already said my piece to her and if
she ever wants to call or text me back
she will
what jay said online was [ __ ]
disgusting okay it does not reflect how
i've ever felt i should have
shouldn't have to say that but i'm
screaming it okay that's good
i'm glad to hear that jeffrey you are
absolved
right obviously well
i'm not there i'm not absolving you but
i'm glad that you disavowed what jay
said and you said it was [ __ ]
disgusting i mean you have to be insane
to not do that but yeah
well he could have just said nothing
yeah but i guess he feels like he's in a
drama now
why are you laughing dan i cut to myself
uh
collapsing so i gotta go every night the
chat is slapping on it
oh this is turning into a scoop now
trisha finally coming out and talking
about jeffree star and hair by
jay really shows how long these things
take to talk about
dude jeffrey and hereby j bowling tricia
is so disgusting
oh we got to change the title of this
episode now
we gotta title it jeffree star and hair
by j
bullying trisha paytas that's true
do you think bowling will get us oh yeah
so hold on maybe verse trisha paytas
jeffrey
did jeffrey really bully her yes back
when they were in vegas
definitely he's saying that he
apologized and that and he's distancing
himself from that
well i get it you're trying to dan are
you serious okay
all right all right i'm just what the
[ __ ] we
just read his tweet i'm talking i'm
click baiting don't you understand yes i
do i understand and it's not even
necessarily not true
he admit to doing oh she she responded
if you didn't want to be involved in the
drama why is he speaking your name in
the video on your behalf confirming all
the hard [ __ ] you guys said about me
i have been cool but he speak on your
behalf multiple time in his feed
dragon girl this show is such a [ __ ]
this is awesome
okay let's work on a title do we have to
do that live
yes this is interesting as we learned
earlier how the sausage made
ian is that interesting
why are you asking ian i don't know
because i haven't heard from him sorry
what was that
it's so interesting nevermind i feel
like that kid when we're like you know
in classes getting out the one kid's
like wait don't we have to turn in
homework or something i feel like that's
what i just did right now
by sending that last tweet it was great
i'm glad you did
so listen keep me updated if there's
more tweets because i don't want to miss
anything okay
all right for sure michelle let me like
this real quick
you go girl
love being in the middle of this i'm not
in the middle i'm just i'm enjoying the
show but i'm team tricia of course all
the [ __ ] way
okay here's the new title
trisha paytas vs jeffree star and hair
by
jay do you want to give someone an idea
of how to propose
to his girlfriend after five years hold
on hold on yeah
i will but but do let help me with this
title guys we need to slam dunk this
is that good enough art
jeffrey starr and hair do people know
who chair by jay i was about to say
who's here by james
arie you're nobody sorry
you're nobody excuse me trish is rubbing
up on you we have some big people
following him
cardi b follows him oh for real yeah
all right i wonder what he says about
her binder back
does anybody you're getting good with
that zach good job man
so fast i like that thank you that's my
that's my dream yeah that's my dream for
you
to be able to be that quick i uh all i
think now is in sound bites
it's like i'm not even joking that's
what i want from you
jeffree star and here by jay but don't
you think like
jeffree star bullied trisha is kind of
epic but we don't like the bully we
don't think bowling will hit land
good like what the i don't think it was
gonna like the word bullying yeah i
don't think so either
but the verse is clean it's not really a
verse it's like
he's being a douche to her
what about what about um squashing the
beef
yada yada and trisha calling
trisha calls in we got to get rid of
squashing the beef nobody could that's
like
that's old news bro that's nothing
[Music]
yeah it's interesting though no people
wanted to hear about that squashing the
beef
with washing the beef and warming up the
tea
then you're muted someone's fun oh come
on
is do people have um suggestions
how about this oh i got a good one okay
shoe nice things were stoned
[Music]
okay wait wait wait trisha paytas
exposes
jeffree star and hairs by jay hairs by
jay
some suggestions uh trisha versus
jeffrey
insane and no i'm not doing the whole
trisha versus mean girl jeffree star
well hold on i think i have a good one
trisha
paytas exposes jeffree star and hairs by
jay
[Music]
[Music]
we love the beef squash okay this is it
tell me if you think it's good trisha
paytas exposes jeffree star
live
live on call teresha
keep the drum roll going zach don't hit
the gong until we decide
trisha paytas versus jeffree star and
d'angelo calls in
[Music]
there's so much action
d'angelo calls but is d'angelo enough is
just his first name
um he's the d'angelo on youtube i mean
there's not another d'angelo
you guys don't like what i said trisha
calls in
and exposes jeffree star it's a little
that is such a good title people
a b zach ian chime in why don't we
insinuate he was at the capitol riots
too
trisha paytas called well trisha paytas
calls in
to expose cue anon shaymin jeffree star
the beef episode featuring trisha paytas
calling
trisha paytas proves conclusively that
jeffree star
is cute jeffree star is cute
shouldn't i said i hate the paul
brothers
okay chill it's kind of irrelevant
that's what we're talking about
thank you you guys like my shout out
paydays
match jeffrey's wig on livestream oh
chef say that again trisha attacked by
unknown hair stylist
like bro by poor poor hairstyle poor
unknown hairstylist
threatened us and a little overweight
yeah um
trish versus jeff starr d'angelo and h3
smashed
should i ate a burger ethan
ethan she did a burger 55
okay here we go trisha paytas
[Music]
keeps restarting trisha
paytas exposes jeffree star
and hair by jay live
that's the one but that's the one i like
there's no it's nobody backing me up
it's not great it's a little like okay
okay
trisha paytas snatches jeffrey's wig
live i mean that's pretty good
what does that mean it's pretty good i
like that one
no what does that mean snatch the wig
well exactly exactly what you just said
what does that mean it draws interest
not really why don't i just call it poo
poo in the duty you know
with wig snatching when someone
unexpectedly and abruptly airs out
somebody's dirty laundry in front of me
do people know what wig snatching is
exactly you know what wig snatching is
no [ __ ] i've never heard that in my
life no idea yeah you have no business
knowing what that is
hayden said like something lovely long
time ago
can you guys have trisha read hamlet on
frenemies
she hasn't done a fast rate in a while
say what
he wants it he wants to read like yeah
okay sure let's do it
it'll be funny to be here not to be this
is the question
i'll try it too
[Laughter]
ten beeps once two
[Music]
okay deangeloni
yeah i'm reading comments
how to lose friends by influential
people
okay i make meats now smoking these
meats here poo poo and duty in a ditch
yeah like oh it doesn't make any sense
it'll make intrigue
[Music]
pork berlin
[Music]
trisha paytas
[Music]
okay that drum roll going zach keep it
going
to beef or not to beef to e3
h3ht trisha sister snatches jeffree star
these are not helpful you guys
[Music]
okay here um this person said oh my
god y'all just do trisha versus jeffrey
and hers by jay
boom i like that there you go okay so
wait
here's the title trisha versus jeffrey
and harris
hair by j trisha paytas
versus jeffrey starr and hare's
[Music]
i don't know why i said that too hair by
jay tricia calls in
live stop dude plus
deangelo
[Music]
don't do the dog on that we're not ready
no he's right
you ran out of time bring the drum roll
back
oh god no okay do we just like trisha
paytas first
jeffree star and here by jay he's got
alfredo
do we like that guys i'm trying to wrap
this up he'll be hold on yeah
i know he's cute that was good poopoo
and dude in a ditch
or
well that didn't create more intrigue i
don't know which one's better
russia finally tells the truth about
jeffrey and kanye
right like trisha finally
oh that's just that's just brutal
all right ian wait so so
trisha finally tells the truth about
jeffrey starr live
no you just changed it but that's good
tricia versus jeffrey and
here by jay done i don't know if that's
good
do people like that it's perfect it's
poo poo and a duty in the ditch
poopoo duty
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right let's take a look let's look
guys what do you what's the best title
here
ian wake up and help me what are you
doing
ian what's the title oh you're working
on thumbnail that's nice
what's the title what's the title ian
just
put jeffrey tricia d'angelo
critic just put their names oh that's
kind of a 15 names in a row
okay let's do this oh jesus
is that what you think trisha paytas
jeffrey starr hairs by jay
d'angelo wallace critical
see i'm seeing yeses we like that
yes and people are begging us to end the
podcast
is that it which isn't usually something
that happens
okay i think you can hit the gong
[Music]
it's poo boy i didn't do it in a day
trisha paytas
jeffrey starr here by jay
d'angelo wallace and critical make it
happen
oh jesus all right we're done
jeffree star hair by j
hair by j jeffrey star
hair by j d and
jello d'angelo wallace whoa
dash h3 after darkness and critical
read it back to me jesus jeffree star
tweeted out i just
landed back in l.a and there's fires is
that real what
and somehow i'm being dragged in someone
else's mess turn the plane right
back around what else is exactly boy you
better own it up
those fires though oh jesus
i'm assuming the drama no it's okay
whatever we'll find out when we
okay so read it to me dan trisha paytas
jeffrey starr here by j d'angelo wallace
critical h3 podcast after dark number
nine is that everything
let's just put alfredo's name in there
don't do it good luck with that
thumbnail ian
for after dark we just do you guys
usually oh we gotta snake them in there
we gotta sneak some faces okay we're not
starting now a conversation all right
guys
we've done it all we've said and we've
done it all
so you're listening you're going to have
a podcast
mexican yeah
what are we thinking today
i mean we've been through a lot to
decide so are you
either making fun of me or you weren't
paying attention
next to the three three three three
curious
man it's burger it's burger you know
it's burger
burger boy have you not been listening
straw poll mexican versus
ian were you listening to the burger
part are you just giving me a hard time
i'm just you know just trying to open up
the opportunity
what are you eating i don't know
parker sounds good you're watching it
you're watching it to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three
[Music]
he doesn't appreciate it's because
at the end of almost every episode you
actually always say you said do you want
mexican
he doesn't appreciate the trauma
this is obviously the source
of decisions
what threw the banana peel down you
404 why are you so shy
i didn't hear what he's saying i just i
didn't hear the words
this has been a long act how long we've
been going all right let's wrap it up
though for real
this is becoming more of a pooper in a
ditch now
a poop and a doodle in a ditch add to
the title
ian roasts ethan oh my god
ian ruins ethan's weekend i'm sorry and
people are saying i'm hangry maybe i am
hungry
you are hungry
i don't want people to start thinking
that like me and actually have beef like
what happened last time
we're gonna have to squash it that's
nice we're gonna have to squash it next
week we know the title in next week's
episode already
ethan and ian squash the beast yeah
all right the song has played twice
again all right then just
cut it i mean why would you say why do
you want mexican food after
everything we've been through this side
we voted on the hamburger
i even got the majority by a miracle of
god
i've somehow convinced ila that it's
okay to get a hamburger
and then you got to come in with the
mexican food question
look i'm saying how much trouble that's
going to cause in my life
all i'm saying is i think you know you
had a lot of beef today
all right yeah i'm leaving too thank you
everyone my
drinks are made while the incest
honestly shredder will stop bopping off
readers at the suite we'll do the real
raw ritual with more and e.t
share relax with the ringer see y'all
look jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three
three you're watching h to the three
three three
you're watching h to the three three
you